The joe rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you've got to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight.
Enter in the code ne Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy from me.
That's the sound of,
of opening a flashlight.
That's what it sounds like.
You seen the new ones?
No,
there's new,
there's a new design.
It's,
it's called the,
I think the pilot or something and it's really slick.
It looks like,
uh,
like an Alienware computer of flashlights.
Like it's just designed really cool.
Like really neat form and like,
do you really see what something looks like though,
while you're fucking it?
Well,
if I'm going to have it on my shelf or in my kitchen,
it looks better.
You know what?
It's not a human though.
I mean,
oh no,
I don't care.
Really.
What do you care what it is?
Just the,
you know,
so if somebody sees it,
it looks cooler.
Kind of like why you buy like a,
instead of buying like a,
you know,
a shitty computer like that,
you get $300 at Fry's.
You see like that?
Wow.
Look at that crazy robot computer.
You know?
That's it.
Oh,
I see.
Cool.
Or to look at,
if you have it in your kitchen,
it's just got more nerd cred.
Yeah,
you should look at it.
If I got a flashlight.com you can actually see,
or you go to your website and click on the link and then opens up flashlight and
then the answer in the code name Brogan and get 15% off.
Yay.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com see like Megan's of Alpha
brain,
the fight.
Maybe someone was on some Alpha brain when they designed that Shit,
man.
It looks like some sort of a bong.
Yeah,
don't do not clot on naked girls.
And I was like,
Hey,
here's a tip while you're at work,
did not click on flesh jack.
I accidentally did that and it becomes the most craziest website ever.
It starts showing a bears and a guy's like hugging each other while using
flashlights.
I like,
look at this,
let's try,
uh,
you just click on this and then next thing you know,
it's just like,
Hey,
look at me looking at my flashlight.
And it's like,
why?
It's like a gay version of,
of the fleshlight,
but it's called Flesh Jack.
It's called the fleshlight flesh Jack Boys.
And it's just a bunch of guys and fucking flashlights with other guys.
But the guys are kissing and I don't know how I got on this one,
but there's one somewhere in here.
There's too hairy men that look like Bert Kreischer and uh,
and uh,
Thompson girl like hugging each other while using a flashlight on each other.
It's,
it's really a horrible,
this is hilarious.
It's dudes masturbating into these flashlights.
Yeah.
I wish I could find it.
What?
To look for the hairy bear guys that are sitting on each other's laps.
It's,
it's,
it's a effort,
a man whacking you off with a fucking fleshlight where your Dick
milkshake cup,
that was a field just whacking you the fuck,
Blah.
Go from there.
Thank you.
Flashlight for promoting freaks are us and shit now.
That's tremendous.
I love it.
Who would like it though?
They would.
Everybody's got their own little kink,
right?
Yeah.
I guess people would like that.
If I was gay and I had wanted my Harry friend to Sipi Jaime and Jack me off
slowly white kissed me in the back
of the neck and start licking inside my years wrestling with my hair.
The reason it'll be
asshole up,
it's often a cop.
I go black off of the cup and be straight and be hanging out with God.
You don't.
All Gay means is that they're sexually attracted to men.
They can do it all kinds of different ways.
Right.
But I leave a little bit like the woman whacking me off.
You want a couple of what I need you for drug,
whatever the fuck that we're currently.
I talked to a gay couple after show once who wanted to correct me and they
wanted to let me know that not everyone who's gay,
uh,
takes in the ass.
So I was like,
all right,
so what do you do?
You just blow each other and the guy was like,
yeah,
basically I my why would you care if that,
that distinction is even out there like w w why would you,
why would you even want anyone to know what your bedroom practices are like?
We know we don't even do that or you don't even do that.
Okay,
why do I need to know this?
You're telling me that people don't,
you know,
they certainly do.
So can't you make fun of that,
isn't it?
It's not.
Okay.
I think it's open waters for them.
Bagger pirates.
I don't have nothing against nobody.
I just don't understand why you got a cup and have a guy come over and whack you
off of it.
I don't get it.
But if that's your,
that's your cane
by women's feet.
A lot of people like a lot of crazy shit.
Like the craziest combinations of Shit.
There's a lot of fucking Weirdos out there,
man.
I used to date a chick that used to suck my fucking liberals.
I hate that
fucking nipples.
She wanted to suck in Nichols cause that's how she got off.
I used to did a Korean chick that you would have to come on her face and then
she would have to masturbate for her to come because the Whoa,
the warmth from the fucking just on her face got her all excited.
That's the only way you can get her to come.
That's the only way that she was a fucking savage
second,
my nipples.
It's like getting a raft rash.
Like when he used to do that body surfing thing on those wraps.
So you that salt water and the sandwich start with like scratching your chest
stopping or a kid.
They don't work.
They're dead.
But I have a friend,
my friend Brian Holloway from executive billiards in white plains,
love girls playing with his nipple.
He'd talk about it too.
He's a freak.
He Goes,
God damn,
I get hard as fuck.
It was really funny.
He was a funny dude,
man.
He was like one of those guys that you hang around with at the pool who always
made everybody.
He was way funnier than me like he was.
He was always saying funny shit there.
What a fucking character.
We always talk about his nipples.
Man,
girl,
you can't touch my nickels man.
Damn.
I think once a girl,
but it's different.
You know,
I think once a girl is with a guy that likes that you,
it's like Gosh,
we think anyway,
life's that.
So they try that shouldn't have first you're like second my fucking,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm trying to crack a nut and you're bringing me back fucking childhood
do to do on at.com o n n I t makers of Alpha brain,
uh,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
The all the information if you have any questions because it's very,
very detailed on,
on at.com.
What's funny,
I got to this point,
I've fleshed,
checked out,
calm worry.
These two,
these two pilots like,
like it's like a storyline thing where they just take off their clothes and
they're like,
hey,
we're piloting now.
We're like working out together with our flashlights naked.
You want to masturbate together?
Air Hangar,
Brian,
I don't think
I would not be as confident in my sexuality as it follows you.
I just think it'd be a traveler to watch those.
I think it's so funny to watch it.
I'm not going to sit there and watch it alone in a house and have to have other
people in the room.
So it's more of a joke.
But
that is a true thing.
You don't want to be what I mean it's all context.
You know?
If you're looking at something and going,
wow,
that's so fucking hot or you know,
I mean you could look at murders and be like,
well,
I mean you have to.
If you're watching something really fucked up,
it should really be in the preference for a lot of other people so you can
evaluate it together.
Yeah.
That's just shocking shit.
Watching something fucked up when you're alone and you have to think about it
and you get scared and shit and you have to it close.
At least two pictures,
a bunch of you together.
You're like,
we're all together.
We're okay.
Let's make fun of this real quick.
I don't like watching creepy shit,
but I don't know.
I'll fucking sleep with the light on and shit I don't like.
None of that stuff at night.
Like the,
I like the exercise was,
and I was just scrolling.
It was like one 15 I think it was Friday night.
Fuck you.
That's the only,
watch the exorcism.
That daytime bitch with a lighter with the fucking day light on.
That was at the time.
Devil.
I'm come out in the daylight though.
At the time.
That was a fucking monster of a moving man.
Whew.
That was a scary movie.
There's some scary fucking movies they'd get to this commercial on a.com Alpha
brain killing me.
You guys know what it is?
Listen,
it's all,
they're all new tropics.
I've,
I've said this 100,000 times in the podcast.
I try not to almost 200 times actually we're,
we're about our 200th episode.
We're separating at the icehouse Wednesday.
Yeah,
so we'll talk about that on the podcast as well.
Jesus Christ,
Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom tech support,
Trump,
tech,
immune.
What are they?
They're all new tropics and,
and the other ones are athletic performance enhancing supplements and the shoot
tech immune isn't immune enhancing supplement.
All the information I need questions you have is all available on [inaudible]
dot com if you order the first order of 30 pills,
if you don't like it,
you get 100% of your money back.
You don't have to send the product back.
We don't want to rip anybody off.
I believe in this stuff.
I've been taking you neutral bics and vitamins and supplements for years and
years and they make a,
they make a big difference,
I think.
I think it's really important to eat healthy,
but I think it's also really important to,
uh,
to take supplements.
I think they've had a tremendous impact on me.
I could feel it.
And especially when you train hard,
if do a lot of work,
you know,
you feel the difference between getting the proper nutrients,
the proper diet.
So get into that first please.
Before you do anything,
Google nootropics,
but if you're interested,
go to [inaudible] dot com and if you enter in a code named Rogan,
you will get 10% off any and all orders.
Um,
so go do that.
Check it out.
Google nootropics is a lot of other companies that have some good stuff.
Bill Romanowski,
is that his name?
He's got a great one called neuro one.
I liked that one too.
So that's it.
Podcasts about start now Jody has is here.
This isn't official Rogan experience
podcast.
[inaudible]
powerful.
Joey Dee,
what's up?
You sexy mother fucker is always good to see him.
My brother.
What's happened?
What's up?
Redman,
that Gif having me off Friday night.
Great time up there at the icehouse chronicles.
The Ice House has been the funds fucking place to hang out is awesome.
We've been having a good time.
That man will put in Pasadena,
the mother fucker.
Shit.
It's a fun place.
So fucking fun place,
man.
It's all nice people,
but it works.
There's nice shows.
It's been fucking great.
All Fun shows.
We're doing this Wednesday,
we're doing a a a show in the big room.
We just announced it.
Tickets just went out up today.
It's really stupid because the show's tomorrow night,
but that's how we do,
you know we don't do much prior planning.
Uh,
but it's a at the ice house in Pasadena in the bigger room and we're going to
have a,
a 200th episode podcast and extravaganza and Joe Diaz a you're going to be
there,
Huh?
No brother.
You know,
I love you motherfuckers.
I'm headed to the fucking capital of Beck.
What's that?
Miami beach.
The improv.
Coconut Grove is all different now.
Now it's very quiet and whole ball doesn't have no more wet Willie's they have
like no more what
I'm staying at the Sonesta hotel,
which is different,
you know,
they have like cocoa walked,
we still got howl at the moon,
you know,
for people who were coked up and want to go in and sing songs and they,
they changed it around.
So it's a different vibe.
I'm excited about going down there,
you know what I'm saying?
What was the last time you were there?
Three,
four years ago.
Three years ago in September or something.
The thing with me.
It was even more than that.
Yeah,
you just go to Fort Lauderdale.
Crazy,
crazy where the wild is crowd I've ever performed in front of like consistently.
It was like doing comedy in another country.
It was doing comedy in the country that just had totally different rules because
everywhere else,
man,
no people didn't talk while shows are going on that fucking Miami Improv man.
They would just just talk while the entire show was going on,
you know,
just have conversations with each other.
I remember there was,
I said something about Oscar de la Hoya and someone,
someone on audience goes,
fuck you man.
Fernando Varguez and then the guy is a man for both of them,
man.
Who else?
Cesar job and then they start arguing Dirac for doing the show about who is like
the better boxer who was like the best box forever.
Like you fucking morons.
Like what are you doing?
You have no control over yourself.
You don't even,
you don't even think it for a second and a show is on.
It wasn't even on their mind,
man.
There was like instant passion toxo plasma infestation running rapid through
their brain.
They're jumping up and you know,
calling out Felix Trinidad,
you know,
it's fucking crazy.
I remember the one night we went,
we were together in a fight,
almost broke out.
Oh yeah.
With the check and the husband and the chick one and it gets spanked and the
husband got mad.
Something to a crazy fact that was going to go out on stage.
And I don't remember when I became friends with the husband and her husband
bought his drinks and that was the end of the day.
There was so much craziness comes in a have place.
I was there that night,
the kid quick.
What's the kid from Boston?
Real Nice.
Sweet guy.
Comic.
He was in big,
uh,
he used to close with we are the world.
Oh Kevin [inaudible].
Kevin Meeney that was there and I,
where he quit.
It was,
no,
no.
You know what happened to Kevin Meeney,
right?
What?
Kevin,
me and he came out of the Queen Gay.
Yeah.
And Greg Fitzsimmons is like really good friends with them.
Good guy.
He says,
all of a sudden the guy's creative.
All of a sudden he's write new material.
He lost a bunch of weight.
Feels great.
It's an amazing,
I was living with a burden bro.
And you know what,
we all kind of fucking knew.
He ain't talked to him,
you know,
and he's really never had a conversation with the guy.
But I remember at one point in time,
man,
he was,
you're really fucking fun.
Yes.
He fell.
He fell off for a while and I don't know why,
but I guess that was it.
It was the burden of being in the closet.
But I went to see him with a friend of mine,
uh,
when we were like maybe 19,
19 or 20 at the most.
I hadn't even done standup yet.
It hadn't started to stand up yet.
And,
uh,
it was at catch a rising star and Cambridge and he fucking destroyed Troy.
We are big pants.
Pete Paul,
he had this thing about big pants and about his family being big pants people.
It was early.
Don't even know why you couldn't,
I couldn't write it down for you on paper.
Why was so funny?
The early nineties yes.
He was very fun.
No,
it was actually before that because I started standing up in 88 so it was before
I started stand up,
so it was probably like 86 I seen him.
He was on fire.
Oh my God.
I'm telling you man.
Kevin Meaney at one point in time had a magic,
he was just one of those guys who can just go on stage,
just start talking about shit.
And it was just funny.
It was just funny.
He just had,
there's a lot of dudes like,
you know how Brody Stevens got that thing where he hits that weird groove and he
could just talk about anything and it doesn't make any sense.
Salt to
the left,
sir.
You know,
he can say something like that.
He just 11 man,
he's going to be a con in tomorrow by the way.
Oh,
powerful.
Brody Stevens.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's amazing what kind of burden them was be living with any secret like that.
I had a friend that I knew for years and he should show it up with girls and
he'd drink and,
but then he drink and he'd just disappear for three months.
And it was that thing he was,
he really was.
Somebody told me they seen him up with an a park with no shirt on with another
guy.
And I was like,
I don't give a fuck and a park.
Yeah.
Like I don't really like hiking,
hiking,
you know,
like Runyon Canyon,
like one of those things.
And I was like,
come on.
I never,
and I asked him and he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
that's what's killing me.
I don't know.
Highlight and what was crazy,
I met her mother said,
man,
movie.
Really?
Yeah.
So you follow me here?
These guys go fuck those gate cock suckers and all.
He's in the middle of all this.
So I could imagine,
I never knew that he was gay till a year or two after we did the fucking movie.
If I
could just imagine how bad,
I'm sure I said some dumb shit.
Well,
I think we've all known a few guys that have struggled with that.
You know,
there's what,
I don't want to say the guy's name,
but there's that one guy who's a real good comic,
but he drinks a lot because he's gay.
He doesn't,
doesn't,
he's not out about it,
you know,
because he's like every single comic.
I know.
He's like,
yeah,
I can't get any.
I'm sorry.
I can't get into specifics as she shouldn't even brought it up.
We have,
uh,
I've,
I've known guys personally and watched them struggle with that.
It's sad.
It's got a fucking suck man.
And it's all just because of intolerance.
Who gives a fuck if someone's gay?
As long as I can trust you to not fuck me when I'm drunk.
Okay.
I don't care.
You know,
I don't care if someone's gay.
Never Jeff,
Jeff Richards from the comic store or your piano,
piano plan.
Dude,
that Guy Jeff Richards,
I call him Jeff.
Richard,
Jeff,
Jeff Bridges is the committee,
the comedian from Saturday night live.
The other guys that he would do pee her.
Why can't I find his last name?
Jeff Scott.
Jeff Scott,
my biology sledding.
I hate that I have too many numbers.
It's called Dunbar's syndrome or something like that.
And you can only store like 150 fucking names and faces in your head.
Something along those lines.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean that guy was like openly gay and the coolest kind of hang out with and
I'm like,
what one of us?
You know,
he was great.
He,
I mean,
who would care?
That's what he's into.
He would joke around about it.
It'd be fun.
Who would care?
I mean,
the only reason why you would care is because you're trying to control something
that's going on inside of you or you've got some weird,
ridiculous notions that are,
you know,
some religious notions about what another person should and shouldn't do.
Other than that,
why do you,
why would you give a fuck?
Like what is that?
Well,
why,
why do people trip out about that?
Because they do pro,
they just do,
you know,
I grew up around it.
My mother had a bar plus she was a half a fag hag.
[inaudible] mother was having a fag hag cause she had the bar,
you know,
and I grew up with it and there was one particular guy that died.
He used to always tease me when I was a kid.
I'm gonna fucking tie you up and then we'll go mommy wave.
And he would just tease me,
you know,
but I never really,
uh,
I tell you where I really learned a lot about the whole gay society.
It was when I got locked up because they had an aids unit and this prison that's
an aid started to get big and they didn't know how to handle them.
And what year was this?
This is 87.
I was very fortunate and he,
they had these barracks that you lived in,
but the aids unit,
you could eat off the fucking floor.
And they had us big TV and they had refrigerators.
So people were like,
we don't talk to those mother fuckers.
But there was a couple of guys that said dog,
they go around and play cards.
They could go down there.
So I'd start going down and I ran my action out of there.
Most of the time my gambling because they had a TV,
a big color TV and they've got to talk to them and asked them how they got the
age.
You know,
some people like,
I don't know how I got it.
You know,
stop it.
You know exactly how the fuck you got to.
You even narrow it down to the night.
Cause once they read you that ride,
you know exactly what night you got it.
And half of these guys were junkers.
There was only five or six in the unit.
There was two guys that got it from sex and the other five got it from junk.
And you know those syringes,
that bloodshed is horrible.
Simply horrible.
And you know,
you talk about,
it's like us right now.
We're like,
yeah,
we go out,
we meet a girl and we tell him to put on a coat.
We put a condom on and shit.
They could,
that's just like fucking without a condom and fucking 20 chicks at night without
a condom.
Sharing your one needle with somebody on the street corner and he'd come up to
you going,
you got $3.
Yeah,
I got to,
let's buy a bag of shit,
a fucking
shit.
A fucking race shit out with beer.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they put beer in it and squirt it out or whatever.
I'm really,
I don't know Joe.
I don't know.
Don't worry.
It's just making it.
I know.
I mean,
I don't think if you're buying heroin on the street with a Syringe,
I don't think you go on a ride eight to buy fucking pharmacy.
Probably don't even know by an alcohol.
Yeah.
You know?
So all those people in the 70s didn't really know.
I mean,
if they do a real statistic count,
how many people just got very thick and they had the pneumonia.
I had HIV.
You know,
it's like they found out years later that,
uh,
what's that shit?
When you get abscesses in your mouth that they kill you?
And they went back in time whenever they had skulls and you could see the
abscesses have grown and they realize now with today's medicine,
they will have saved these people.
You know?
You don't know that shit.
We don't fucking know.
So,
but just a burden to living with something like the burden I had even with just
somebody trying to hide an addiction,
that's a burden.
Burden is me being gay or they're not wanting somebody to know when we being a
fief at night or me being the ice man and killing people and coming up with my
family,
the daytime,
those burdens after weight dramatically on you.
They weren't your mad cause they go into deep into your psyche.
It's a secret.
So it somewhere along the line if it affects you,
there has to affect the other parts of your life and eventually you're going to
blow cause youtube borrow from Peter to pay mobile are Paul emotionally,
which is the fucking worst when you're playing with your emotions,
right?
Yeah.
And you know,
and when you're constantly spending energy trying to trick yourself and
everything is all right.
That's like you don't,
you don't even have half your brand because it's like your whole brain is in
conflict.
Like give you like the rest of the thinking of planning and looking objectively
at your future.
That doesn't even take place because all you're doing is dealing with whatever's
fuck one.
Yeah,
whatever.
Whatever weird issue it is.
Humans are so strange,
man.
It's so strange how we lock onto behavior patterns like that.
Like you'll,
you'll see people,
they'll get addicted to gambling.
I mean that's a simple behavior pattern.
Some something happened along the line and their mind,
their reward system got completely addicted to these giant jolts that they get
from risking money.
And when they don't have that,
they don't feel alive when they do a regular job and sit there with what,
you know,
what they would call squares and just sit around all day with a bunch of fucking
people that just,
you know,
don't want to take any chances and get put 15% on every tip.
You know,
they,
they want to fucking roll dice.
They want to see what happens.
They want to give it a chance and they get suckered in and then it consumes
them.
I've seen guys,
I've seen guys become homeless gambling junkie.
I've seen it.
I've actually seen them.
The hoarder.
You used to have an apartment.
Yeah.
That guy.
But,
uh,
guys from the pool hall,
from back in the in white plains.
I saw a couple of guys go homeless.
There was a,
there was a lot of older dudes especially that would like in their sixties and
seventies come in yelling about a fucking horse.
That's motherfucker comment five taking it on the yelling the numbers out for
the lottery.
I got five,
six to seven the motherfucking five [inaudible]
all the things I've read it,
all the shows I've seen about gambling because it's always fucking,
because my mother was hooked so I was successful.
I was successful to that.
Susceptible to that disease.
I didn't say I was 18 you know,
deep down inside these people want to lose adaptable.
These people want to lose.
Yes.
That's why they,
I mean nobody ever says to,
I just got a ticket.
I just got fucking pulled over.
Fucked in the ass.
These people come in and sit there and drink and going,
what's up dog?
Those fucking Boston Celtic motherfuckers.
They didn't cover the spread.
They'll tell you that whole night and how they're down 12 how Camara and you're
looking at him like,
oh my God.
And I almost got hooked on gambling.
Joe,
when I was 18 I was close and I figured out that this was the cocaine logic.
I figured out that I had two vices.
I like to gamble and I like to snort.
I had to pick one,
pick the other.
There's nothing with code pushed.
The Gail who got to your life comes like this can really get into this is good
because one thing I was,
you know when you were evicted,
you're weak and you're vulnerable to money and the quick score,
but I also knew
there was another side to that coin and the coin was that you have to pay
somebody.
If you lose an 85% of the time,
you lose.
And let me tell you something,
if I'm going to give somebody 600 hours,
listen,
if I'm selling blow and I'm mugging people and I'm making four or five grand a
week,
I don't mind giving you a grade.
That's a cost of doing business.
You know what I'm saying?
Your app there,
you're talking shit,
I got some Sandvik conversation,
but if I'm earning a living,
like I got to get up and go to work.
Guys had been,
I got to give my money or some idiot because I bet the fucking Nixon,
they want to play fucking jungle handball and I'm not going to cover this
fucking spread here.
Forget it.
So I said,
if I'm going to take,
if I'm going to get wasted $200 on gambling,
I might as well spend two alarms.
I snot and,
and look out a window and get something out of it.
At least I'm paranoid.
You know what I'm saying?
I get something out of it.
You know a assurance is like gambling.
When you buy insurance,
they don't give you nothing.
You signed a paper.
That's why insurance is the hardest sale on the fucking world.
You get a history.
It's like gambling.
When you lose,
we getting,
it's the same fucking logic.
Like it's nothing.
There's nothing.
It's just a transfer of paper.
What is gambling at the end?
When you gamble on something,
it's not,
you could gamble on yourself that go fight Jon Jones,
which I guy,
I could get on the fucking horse myself.
It's the same kind of logic,
Joe Rogan.
We get nothing for it just to transfer a fucking money and it always ends up.
You've given up that fucking cash.
It never comes the other way.
Every once in a great while he's there.
Anybody that's like a really good gambler that's out there making a living
gambling.
Yes,
but their,
their iqs have to be fucking phenomenal and they'll inch roll and they have to
have the control of an older gentlemen.
You have to,
you have to know this is a seem the God damn,
what did I give you?
80 grand on a Friday night.
You're going to Vegas and you're going to fucking Kadesh and in the ass you're
going to send every fucking dime of it.
But a controlled gambler is somebody who says,
you know what,
just because there's a game on Tuesday,
don't mean I got a gamble.
I'm saving my money for Thursday.
In fact,
I'm going to call it.
They out with the book.
They call it the book and fuck with the book.
Hey,
it's Tuesday,
but what's the line on Thursday?
And they start fucking with the books and started calling.
It's a system of Joe and the people who make money.
It's like anything else,
Joe Rogan,
this comics like man,
don't have millions.
You know what I'm saying?
And then there's comics that figured out how to become a a,
a label and a and a business at.
The same thing happens with gambling.
This people would just come and go through gambling and when they go,
they lose a house.
You know,
A wife can cause a job because of the affects everything.
But with fucking,
yeah,
I mean it ain't had my friend Jimmy Burke on and story.
If his childhood,
his dad would just go off,
go off,
just go off and go money and lose the house and that would be it.
No,
the biggest gambling loser was of our time.
John Gotti,
a million a month,
the cash,
250,000 on a weekend.
He was making 12 million a fucking year shoe.
Once in a while.
The feds got documents.
They were thinking of putting the thing on the biggest loser ever.
Sports wise.
It did generate most
of it.
I'll look at a guy like that go that motherfucker dressed in $2,000 suits when
he was just walking the streets.
Yeah.
How much was he really stealing?
He was stealing because he was a degenerate gambler from the fucking cards to
fucking dice,
to fucking sports,
to everything,
and he would lie.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he lie about his losses.
He got him and go,
I need 300,000 to put money out in the street.
No,
he was losing,
but on the other hand,
the guy was loyal because he paid his debts.
A lot of people like that.
I'll just say,
suck my Dick.
What are you going to do with John?
Gotti paid his debts.
He paid every fucking dead.
Nobody ever said the guy didn't pay his debt to pay this debt,
but he was disgusting gamble.
He's so weird.
My boss,
he was all the sudden like he was a star.
It was really strange.
It was like the first one that seemed to like relish the role.
You know,
remember when they couldn't catch him with anything and they'd call him the
Teflon Don.
And he thought that he'd had that big bald dude that it was a mafia tile style
lawyer.
Remember that?
What was that guy's name?
Yes.
Bruce Cutler.
And he was his lawyer and he was like the celebrity lawyer for John Gotti and
heal the way,
the way he always defended them.
It was like,
Whoa,
this guy's got this like super intelligent bulldog legal guy on his side and
he's just,
just gonna just fucking do battle with the system.
Meanwhile,
everybody knows he's a,
you know,
he's the head of organized crime and they're trying to figure out how to pin it
on him.
It was the weirdest thing watching it all play out.
Like in the news.
It's like,
how has this guy,
this guy is just running around like you'd know he's the organized crime guy and
they're just trying to figure out how to bust them.
Like it's a real strange,
it's like watching like law and order play out like that where they,
they're,
they're convinced the guy is guilty,
but they can't get a conviction for a long time.
They couldn't get a conviction on him.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
that was his nickname is the beauty of,
is a,
is a May.
We're going to New York.
I don't know if Brian's going to know who's going.
So dot already and within a minute.
And one of the nights when we get that we're going to go to sparks steak house
and park outside.
Is that the place where,
uh,
you just got to park outside and I want you to just sit close your eyes and
think about the balls it takes to shoot somebody at five 30 on Christmas a week
at that place.
Just the balls too.
Because once he did that,
who's going to argue with you?
Right?
You didn't shoot him in the head.
He didn't poison him.
He got five guy,
he talked,
taught five guys.
So he went and plugged Brodie,
Ari Dunkin,
and to going around the kind of shooting this motherfucker when he comes out and
he got away with it in broad daylight.
All of them shot him at once.
All of the five fucking guns coming at your pap and grow on a only cried Gravano
and whatever.
We're in a car and he talked five guys to shoot.
They call themselves the fist to five hands and they just went out there and
shot this motherfucking five 30 at night,
December 15th or something.
When you sit there and you feel what it takes to get that,
that's when you'll go,
I get it.
I get what this guy did.
He did.
You know,
he,
he uh,
he did something that was on,
you know,
that's amazing.
Shooting somebody at the House of Blues at eight o'clock at night during the
premiere.
This guy did something that was just ballsy.
There was no argument after that.
Like he just took off.
So what?
What was it that everybody thought?
It was just so crazy after that that he had to do that.
They were going to kill him because he was selling heroin.
He said,
I'm going or you're going bitch.
And he would talk to everybody and he goes,
here's the deal.
I'll cut you as in,
we'll all become millionaires,
but this motherfucker's got to go.
Whoa.
And they sat down,
they set up a fake meeting to meet everybody there.
And these motherfuckers got out of the car and five guys got out dressed was
Russians with the hats,
with the little jackets like they were donating and started unloading on these
guys.
Whoa,
look at the pictures.
Look at the pictures,
the guys on the street with a top item,
but blood coming out.
But the thing would happen with God.
He is what Alex Jones talks about.
They went after God.
The first time,
God,
he fucked him up spitting that face.
God.
He will listen.
When you beat the government,
you take your money,
you take your pieces and you go home.
The government ain't gonna stand that.
The government is a business.
The government puts $1 million a year,
the following Joe Rogan.
Eventually we're going to collect on that investment and we're going to do
whatever it takes to collect on that investment.
My friend,
that's it.
Plain and simple.
When the government wants you,
they're coming to get you.
And that's one situation where he beat him.
He beat him with jewelry.
Tamping,
they went back at him,
he beat him again with something.
Then they put wires everywhere,
which the wires a fucking illegal.
They put them everywhere and they still,
but the guy talked,
they're not illegal anymore.
No,
but the guy,
uh,
you know,
the guy heard himself talking.
I mean the guy was a moron.
Let's face it,
he hurts himself.
He's just such a buck wild guy to be in control of an organized crime or you
know,
a big thing like the mob people bringing you money.
Can you imagine crazy?
Well just come on Thursdays and bring you 80,000 Tripoli brings you a hundred
grand.
I bring you 40.
This is it.
This is what you do.
Can you imagine if all wires were illegal?
Like all wires?
Our white wires everywhere.
Like you weren't allowed to have wires.
Fuck,
are you talking?
You know,
and it's very sad that the government doesn't know.
Is that all right?
Cool.
Gravano whatever the fuck you want.
I mean,
you know,
I just read something the other day about this motherfucker that got gotta re
convict them because at night he's still alive.
He's still alive,
but he's all fucked up crazy and 80 he's in Colorado and Tomahawk under the
fucking prison and he's all fucked up from the steroids.
His hair fell out of his teeth are falling out.
He's got some central nervous disease like Mitzi shore.
You shakes and shit.
God bless him.
But
the fuck you blessed.
You know when the government took,
Kevin talked to him and pretty much riding on this guy.
You know what?
They just really,
they just realized all his sins that he never capture.
Now he's getting convicted because now they've drawn everything out.
And 83 he was going around buy lottery tickets.
So he you knew in the neighborhood,
if you hit the lottery for 800,000 it was a million comes to Gravano.
He'll buy the ticket because then he had a legal way of getting income.
Let me fucking tickets.
He bought that year he'd tickets.
That idiot bought that year,
800 a million cash.
He bought off the people.
Holy Shit.
So he would have annuities.
Oh Wow.
So it just made it look like he was just winning the lottery left to right.
Everybody in his house wasn't a lottery.
One year,
the daughter,
you know that Whitey Bulger did that to Whitey Bolger won the lottery twice.
The balls are these cocksuckers never ends.
But here's the weird thing that I've told you this before,
when at the end,
after they had Gravano,
when they will make it a loan,
shark collections,
he was still calling the people going,
I don't give a fuck if I'm in prison.
You're going to have to feds go home,
buy it and pick it up.
The money,
faster crowd.
That's documented.
The people plan and clouds how much they wanted,
but they kind of deal with the devil.
They just cut a deal with the devil just to go after fucking this degenerate new
do.
Ivana was like easily just as bad.
Right.
I mean,
the stuff that he had done justice bad,
right.
He murdered a bunch of people,
right?
Yeah,
but he was,
he wasn't like a straight up guy.
He was like a fucking con guy icon.
Like you were big.
Oh God out.
Yeah.
He got out for a while.
That's what people don't understand.
Like the government let a known killer out.
He talked him out of it.
He was a,
he was a tremendous negotiated.
He got the keepers 20 million.
He got five years and that was it.
He got to keep his 20 million from illegal and devotees and then what happened?
He was like selling ecstasy in Arizona,
Arizona.
That's when we met the daughter at the Improv.
The daughter came through his show that time,
the one,
that's how my boys now that Chubby one came to one of our shows and the Tempe
one time with your buddy.
The [inaudible] or the bodybuilding guy.
He had a bunch of boards with him and in front of I said something about the
town that Sammy the bull and afterwards he goes,
I got his daughter here.
Be careful what you're saying.
Well that was his daughter that was there with us.
That one.
This is [inaudible] 98 I can barely remember,
but I'm kind of remembering it now.
Yeah,
that was a lot of freaks dog.
Well Arizona's this range.
Strange Ryan pointed out to me once we were in Scottsdale and we were hanging
out and having a good old time and Brian goes,
everyone's on coke.
Everybody else you look around going to say he,
he clued me in on the the mannerisms and he goes,
go walk up to them.
They'll be having a conversation whether it be really fucking sincere but there
could be talking about what's better,
coke or Pepsi.
Love it.
Like right when I say that we looked over and everybody at the same time,
it's like wiping their nose and going down like this.
Like it was just weird.
It was like a movie.
It was.
If it was,
if it was in a movie,
it would be too over the top.
You'd be like,
Nah,
there's not that many people on Coke at the club,
but this place was,
it was ridiculous.
I don't know if it's still like that.
You know,
cultures that coke the coke comes and goes,
like people always gonna want coke,
but the coke cultures like kind of die off a little bit.
There's a lot of people try to get their act together.
You know,
there's a lot of people don't like the way that that wrecks their fucking body
and they're trying to get out of it.
I really,
really put white powder on your nose.
You're
really,
really am.
I really,
really,
really would like to know the amount of coke that comes into just our country
every year just to figure it the fuck out.
Do you think like,
I don't like gotta be,
it's gotta be in the metric targets.
Where do you think it's coming in?
How do you think it's getting here in Mexico,
but what,
like who's bringing it down and say like big cut their hands.
The Columbia is growing now and they said,
look,
we've got too much money.
Really.
We've been doing this for eight years,
was sick of this shit.
Cotton and governments and helicopters could do this.
Come down by a package,
so it's an awesome neighborhood.
They get the old days.
He the Colombians.
In the old days,
a guy named Carlos like dad went to the metal link card Coulson.
You motherfuckers don't know nothing about transporting.
You guys are missing the boat here.
You guys are just salad.
Fuck that shit.
We're going to sell it,
transport it,
take it to the United States,
cut it,
sell it again and we're going to take all that profit a to z.
We're just not going to make our money and ABC.
We're going to go a to Z,
right to the fucking streets.
We're going to put our people in there.
This guy was a college educated fucking coke dealer and he went and he booked
that island,
Barbados,
whatever.
The one that blow that's supposed to be Carlos laid there.
He was the one that the methylene cartel gave him up when Bush wanted something.
I got to get some guys.
You guys are down there and making millions.
We've got,
you know,
because they went down and just told Noriega Tova give us the keys to your back
book.
Give us your back book.
Give us the name of the dealer because we're in on that 10% and we're taking
everything you're getting.
You know what you're getting.
What's behind door number?
Hey,
20,000 a plane ticket and the Yo,
Yo,
we always throw in a Yo,
you know what Louis North Noriega was an unknown drug trafficker,
right?
That was the deal.
He was just running Panama,
right?
It's the real deal.
Here's the deal with the Colombians.
Colombians have a saying,
what?
Six same Bryant,
blah,
blah.
That's not what I was thinking.
That means maybe you're taking a bundle or you're taking cash.
I know you're Catholic and you're Christian and your wife goes to church every
Sunday,
but it's either boom or whatever Bob Butoh plop out.
So it will be your corrupt or not.
You either take the money or with a pull of blood.
You had them.
We're gonna replace you with somebody who will take the money.
I was thinking,
puts them on to Noriega.
Noriega was,
and then there's funneling hundreds of millions of pounds of coke to his island.
And let's pretend he's getting a penny of fucking ounce.
It is a kind of an amazing gangster movie though.
You got it,
man.
All of them.
I mean,
if you look at,
if you just look at human civilization,
if you looked at it as like a a numbers game and saw the incredible scores,
the United States is pulled off,
you know,
putting,
putting side over,
say it in the power,
arming him.
Two pictures of him shaking his hand.
If you know,
the years later,
it's storming.
Is City shooting missiles and hanging him on a stairwell awesome.
Just before they're gonna go on 60 minutes.
Those motherfuckers,
it's amazing.
It's beautiful.
It's amazing.
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's terrible and it's horrible and it's awful and it's,
it's disgusting that that's how humanity works.
But if you just look at it from like a sheer mathematic standpoint,
like,
wow,
what does,
that's why it's staggering achievement.
This one fucked up country as you know,
has had all over the world.
That's shit you posted the other day,
dude.
It was tripping me out.
But which one?
Like the ones and Zeros or everything's a code and fucking codes inside.
That is a really bizarre,
I have to go over that a bunch of times because there's a lot of gobbilty goop.
I don't understand.
I don't,
you know,
I,
it was,
it was a Neil Tyson degrasse,
is that how you say it?
Yeah.
And it was another professor and um,
I don't remember the other professor's name and I should look that up because it
was a really fascinating,
but what,
I don't understand that what they're pretty much,
they're finding a code computer code and things.
I can't now that that's the part problem I had trying to figure out like what
were the things that they're finding the code in but what they were kind of
getting at that for some reason that they're finding that life seems to be a
computer code and that we might all be a semi assimilation of are like ourselves
simulating ourselves and like a computer right now.
Yeah.
This is a,
this is,
by the way,
this is really fairly recent to this whole thing.
You could pull it up and this guy can uh,
can,
can say it and we can sort of like figuring out what the fuck it means.
Just do have on youtube a strange computer code discovered concealed in
superstring code,
discovered concealed in superstring equations.
What the fuck's a super,
let's,
let's let him talk and then try to ape our way through the most rudimentary of
explanations.
Yeah.
That,
that gentleman with the glasses but whole code before
the opening.
It was weird.
Yeah.
Let me get it saying what if it really existed?
Meet Professor James Gates Jr theoretical physicists and John as told professor
of physics.
At the University of Maryland.
This is all like on the screen with graphics while working on super string
theory,
professor gates discovered something very interesting hidden within the
equations.
See for yourself,
one of the viewers responsible for his own conclusions.
My channel's not responsible for any potential mental
instability.
This main sea,
are they,
are they trolling?
Viewer discretion is advised.
Are they trolling?
Here we go.
It's march seven well,
partly it's taken to this very strange images that are behind your head right
now.
These are pictures of equations I've been for the last 15 years trying to answer
the kinds of questions that my colleagues here have.
Habit reasoning and what I've come to understand is that there are these
incredible pictures that contained all the information of a set of equations
that are related to string theory.
And it's even more bizarre than that because when you then try to understand
these pictures,
you find out that buried in them,
our computer codes,
just like the type that you find in the browser,
when you go surf the web,
you say your attempt to understand the fundamental operations of nature leads
you to a set of equations that are indistinguishable from the equations that
drive search engines and browsers on our computers.
That is correct.
So I'm still,
wait,
I have to just be silent
to lunch.
That again.
So you're saying as you dig deeper,
you find computer code written in the fabric of the cosmos into the equations
that we want to use to describe the cosmos.
Yes.
Computer Code,
strings of bits of ones and Zeros.
It's not just sort of resembles computer code.
You're saying it is computer code.
It's not even just his computer code.
It's a special kind of computer code that was invented by a scientist named
Claude Shannon and the 1940s that's what we find very,
very currently inside the equations that occur in string theory and in general
in systems that we get caught say are supersymmetric.
Some of those codes are showing on the screen behind you right now.
They don't look like codes,
but these pictures which we call a dink groves or graphical representations of
sets of equations that are based on codes that in the description of our
universe that is a super symmetrical universe which we were gonna test in the
LHC.
If you believe that description,
I can show you the presence of these codes.
That's my statement.
Do you have any protect predictions in your ideas or any ways to test any
videos,
any more than saying the guy over on the screen?
The work that I'm doing is in fact Sophia radical that we don't,
we don't understand yet whether it is even possible to complete the program.
We have found these strange graphs.
We know that they are equivalent to equations and we have found in these
equations computer codes and so that's where we are right now.
So I cannot give you a prediction.
This work is less than two years old.
Jesus Christ.
I don't understand a fucking word what you're saying that that was like I do and
I don't folks,
if you're at home screaming,
listening to this,
well what he's trying to see quite simply is that the computer that they're to
decipher everything that the equation,
the math that they're using to explain the,
the Co has code in it,
but that's like,
that makes no sense.
Very difficult to wrap your head around because what I understand was that he
was saying the computer that they're using to represent all this stuff,
they're finding it,
they're finding the code in it when they're trying to represent it with a
computer.
Right.
I,
I don't know what that means.
I heard like the equations that they're using to explain this string theory or
something like that,
like in those equations,
they're finding computer code,
right?
Like what's an equation?
There's an equation already.
Fucking math.
I'm not quite sure what they're trying to say by by saying that,
it's like as they're following,
as they're using their computer code,
the computer represents the universe or he represents whatever they're trying to
zero in on.
Then they see a pattern that exists in ones and Zeros and they're saying that
it's very clear that it's a specific type of pattern that was a invented by one
certain sciences,
so,
so they know exactly what the code should be,
but what the fuck does that mean?
Or this isn't really hilarious.
Improv comedy class video,
Viral v w we have to stop.
I mean it sounds stupid.
All right.
This is,
this is one of those weird conversations where you got to go walk.
Why are you even bothering to have this conversation?
But the reality is when you look at some of the video games that are available
right now just for your iPad and this,
this is an incredible leap of say just mean my lifetime.
I was around when Pong came out,
when we had pong,
when I was a kid,
it was the shit.
He couldn't believe that you could make something move on the TV.
And it was a black and white TV by the way.
We were playing pong.
And to go from that in our lifetime to what we're seeing now graphically,
I can only imagine that if you could go a thousand years forward from now,
can you imagine we were,
we're easily going to have some sort of an artificial reality real.
The real question is,
is this it?
Is this the artificial reality of some other reality?
Are We,
you know,
are we plugged in somewhere?
I mean,
there's this really like the fucking matrix.
are we in some sort of a,
a,
a perfect state of being able to completely control reality and some distant
point in the future where we're just locking our consciousness and do these
crazy scenarios?
I,
when I first heard this,
when you first tweeted it,
I now find myself trying to do something like to get out of this thing.
And now I think I'm going crazy.
Like I was talking to my cat and I'm like,
if you know this is a simulation,
like like lick your lips right now,
you know he's doing that kind of test and
like I'm looking now to see if I could hack if this is a reality thing.
But when you hear stuff like when you hear stuff like this that you don't quite
understand,
but what they're trying to say essentially is it's there's some sort of a code
everything and then it looks like,
you know like look,
it looks like even like the possibly as it had been designed,
I mean they didn't say that specifically,
but that you know,
the,
if there is a mathematical code doodle,
not even saying designed by like an entity,
maybe just designed by nature,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
But you got to think that they're going to be able to,
they're going to be able to simulate that eventually they're gonna.
If they can get to that,
they're going to go from that and then they're going to go to the next stage.
What does the next stage,
you know,
how do they take things for the house technology take us further and further
down the road till the point where we might one day be living inside a fucking
computer program and that shit might be going on right now.
It's
totally man.
It's one of those conversations.
What a fucking trip that will be and what if it's live?
It is.
What if it's something like,
like remember when you were in elementary last show.
He's fucking picking shit up and stared at it.
He stared at a USB cable like into the secrets to the University of it.
We went way too deep into the wood.
If drawer for Joe Dog.
I ain't a fucking half chocolate triple Bob before.
I know you guys are scaring me.
Like Star Trek.
What does she,
she came out and I was a kid.
I was always scared of Star Trek.
The music.
I would shut that motherfucker off as long.
As soon as I heard
fucking shut that TV off,
I switch off or something.
What if we come out of this,
this virtual reality world and it's something like we go back to him like third
grade when we were having to,
they were checking us for lice and that's when they started it.
Like they like,
they like fucking like put a needle in the back of her neck and then send it,
put us in this pod and then like you wake up and you're that kid again and
you're like,
hmm.
All right.
So that's exactly what life is and that's how it could happen,
you know,
and stuff.
Wow.
And you're like great style.
You don't like when somebody goes to you don't like what?
I'm not sure I follow you.
I'm not going to just to,
just to explain it a little better because this is what fucks me up all the time
and this is what I see happening.
That fucking kills me being alive and say a hundred years number,
the Hannibal and one of those stupid movies,
he drew a picture and she came to visit him and she goes,
did you draw that?
And he goes,
I drew from memory and he's Spiderman.
During the face.
Yeah.
Well that was migs.
It's really weird because people do that.
They go somewhere and they just remember something that they seen from it and
they draw something from memory,
which is pretty fucking brilliant,
especially when you have little things that nobody else would know.
That means you caught that why you were there,
you know,
which really weird that maybe 30 40 years from now you could put a hat on,
close your fucking eyes.
You can go to Italy for the day.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or the forever day and come back and it's going to cost you $89 and you're going
to get on a bus tour.
And the truly gonna fucking take you.
Have you ever had,
uh,
it experienced any sort of a psychedelic experience that you felt like lasted a
long time and then you came back and it was like,
you know,
you,
it would only,
it only been like 10 minutes,
20 minutes.
That's what that are said.
He said he went somewhere for over a month.
He said he was the,
I think he said for months,
he felt like he felt like he had friendships there and he was going to miss
people and he was like living in some strange fucking
parallel world.
No Salvia.
And he said he came back 10 minutes later and he was,
and he was just completely freaked out.
It took them so hard,
it was so hard for him to readjust because only 10 minutes have gone by.
But to him months had gone by now.
So I,
but we,
we talked about on the podcast and I can all these tweets from other people that
said they had the exact same thing happen to them.
You feel like,
like while it's happening though,
you have like this weird sense that like,
Hey,
I know all about this already.
Like I've been here,
I've felt this before.
And you know like that's the craziest part about the DMT experience.
The craziest part about that is that that same feeling of [inaudible],
I know this.
Yeah,
I know this place.
I know what I'm saying.
When I first started tripping.
I like tripping with a group.
When I was 1514 you tripped with a group,
right?
It was a completely different experience.
When we all pop it together,
it's six,
we drink beers,
we wrote 15 joints and smoke them,
and then eight 30 you're tripping and now you're with friends and you're with a
walked right.
The scariest thing for me was going home 12 one o'clock because you're by
yourself,
right?
This is the most important part of the trip is answering your questions to
yourself.
And I'd go home and I go in and out,
like I'd put a pink Floyd out mud,
you know,
dark side of the moon.
And for two songs I was fucking gun,
but for two other songs I was there saying to myself,
Ooh,
I got it together now.
Now I'm ready to dawn.
Thank God this trip has done.
And just as how it was getting up,
that motherfucker came back to it again.
That's the difference when you do really good acid.
Now last week I've been working a lot on my neat with the bike.
You told me stationary bike.
So I usually go over that 45 an hour and I put it on.
And for some reason,
you know,
they always say I was cracking jokes.
You guys wants to,
sometimes you hide your weed and you don't know where you put it,
but you get higher and you'll find it.
You know,
like it's just amazing when you in that consciousness again,
fuck,
I know what my weaknesses are.
The fucking car.
Right.
Just remember cause your eyes right.
And it's show we had the other day I was listening to a bro,
Joe Rogan and Brian,
this is the weirdest thing that happened.
I went early and I had gotten up and I slogan I had a great breakfast and I went
to the thing and I put it on don't quarter by led Zeppelin alive and he's got a
piece in there that's Jimmy page playing the guitar.
That right there and answers all your questions about life.
And I'll never forget what I was sitting there riding the bike.
I'm high.
And it took me to where I was and I remember that it wasn't a fucking,
it wasn't a fuck him.
Nah,
it was at a guy,
Gunter Brown's house that started good,
good,
good.
Gunter Brown.
If you asked me to get another knock it down,
he was like this dirty white guy,
but he was a millionaire.
He's father and vet the Dixie Cup with the jokes or something.
And this guy was basically a junkie.
Like you go over there and he'd say,
you want you to dick stuff that got a chicken will suck your Dick,
why you're taking this shit.
Like he always had weird dirty white women over there.
And one time I went on,
I'm like 17 and I did a line of white heroin and he goes,
I got to go run an errand.
I'll be back.
And he left that album on.
And I remember that I was sitting up,
but in my mind I was in my fetal position and I was in my mother's womb and I
could hear her heartbeat.
And even though I was,
all I could hear was Jimmy Page's guitar.
And every time I was straighten up,
I would see people,
they're not judging me.
It was the fucking warmth to the room.
And the warmth was just amazing.
It was too much.
And in one corner was like Buddha,
the other corner was like Jesus.
Every corner was like a God that I didn't even know,
like a Hindu,
a Korean with a fucking sword.
And they weren't that judging me.
They were just there waiting for something.
And I remember I would go into the womb and come out of the womb and every time
I go into the woman coming out of Jimmy page or keep playing that fucking guitar
and I could hear my mother's heartbeat,
my mother was dead this time.
So what's your site?
Keep taking over that fucking trip.
And I get here and every time I would pop up,
I would see every woman that ever came into my life dog,
whether I knew them or not.
Your lunch woman,
your first grade teacher,
the fucking nurse that delivered you to your mother's hands and all of a sudden
dog.
I remember the Virgin Mary came out doing a strip fucking teas and this is why I
was,
I'm in this fucking thing and I don't want to look at the Virgin Mary's Pussy,
but she takes off her fucking number these and I'll never forget that her pussy
was like a picture of me at that age and there was a guy sitting there the whole
time I'm sitting in this room position,
but there's a guy with his back to me going,
you don't need the answers.
They got fear.
I got the real mother fucking answers to your problems and at that time you're
going,
I don't need your help bitch.
The Virgin Mary's in front of me.
I got the answer,
motherfucker.
And I remembered that heroin trip hop,
I never,
I cleaned up after that for about a month.
It was so real and it was eight hours and that he stayed the Virgin Mary's Pussy
was him as a child,
as a meat.
It was like me with a little afro and I was like,
oh,
and I forgot that for 20 fucking years.
Look my balls,
the itching,
you know what I'm saying?
That's how strong that fucking story.
No wonder I always wanted to touch it.
Never fucking,
and I didn't do it for years after that.
Like I was like,
that's a little too fucking Straw.
That's why when you guys talking about that DMT warm smile,
that warmth is universal like that.
When you're there at that other level,
it's just this and you're tripping.
You're waters,
but something's telling you you will cry.
It's very loving.
I mean,
people who have bad trips,
um,
you know,
I don't know what your particular chemistry is,
but a lot of it,
I do believe,
and this is,
you know,
I'm no expert clearly.
I do believe a lot of it,
the shit that's fucking with them already and it's every dancing.
It could be that no bad trip is basically somebody going to try to control their
own budget with a bad trip is seeing yourself.
Oh,
okay.
So all of this because when you're done the outcomes,
some people do it a few times and they enjoy it and then they'll do it one time
and have a bad trip because they seem themselves,
but they do it the first couple of days because we did it in a circle.
We didn't go home and the phone rang and you seen your face in a mirror of
fucking melting.
That's what you felt and you felt warmth than you.
You sat down and all the sudden you feel like eating and your dog and also you
start thinking of your childhood and where you went wrong and all the secrets
that you have inside of you and now they were in front of you and you've got to
deal with them.
That's your bad fucking trip.
That is what it is.
It's really,
you got a lot of fucked up shit in your own life that you,
you,
you don't appreciate getting illuminated and it's freaking you out.
It's yourself.
It's when you trip.
That's,
I only say from my personal experiences,
that's been my personal experience.
When I've had a bad trip.
It's always been a,
and I haven't had anything that was really bad,
but I've had some pot ones that were,
I had a few pot moments when I first started smoking where I just got way too
blast and then I just couldn't swim yet.
I didn't know what I was doing yet and I was just getting overwhelmed by these
waves because what would happen was,
um,
when,
when you,
whenever you're in even a mild psychedelic like pot,
what it does is it sort of brings you into some different place.
And if you're trying to resist that in any way,
if you're trying to fight that in any way or control it in any way,
it's going to overwhelm you.
Especially if you take enough,
if you take enough to get paranoid and freaked out.
The reason why it's so effective,
like you can learn so much from it is the same reason why it's so impactful when
it happens while you,
while you can't control it,
it's just slipping away from you and you will get overwhelmed with these like
self realizations and it could have been,
it could be from shit from a decade ago man.
Absolutely.
It can be an old,
an old girlfriend where you said one crucial thing 1520 years ago and you feel
like a Douche bag today.
You know,
things that you said when you were 15 can haunt you.
I mean I've,
I've had that happen,
but I think that's all like to get you to look at yourself in a,
in a,
in a really honest way,
it's theirs.
It's very difficult for us to do.
I think most of us like to,
you know,
put our blinders on,
put our blinders on and just sort of stumble through this and make it look as
pretty as it possibly can along the way.
And pretend and pretend that we're doing everything correctly,
but to really like assess when,
you know,
it's,
it's almost like forcing yourself to go to school on yourself.
You know,
people don't want to do any more schoolwork than they already have to,
you know,
if I can get off work at five o'clock and I'm done for the day,
there's no more thinking done at,
there's yourself improvement,
suck my Dick,
I'm going to sleep,
you know?
Gimme my Ambien,
stop yelling at me.
You know?
And I think,
uh,
I think that's,
that's,
that's a part of it too.
I think people were,
a lot of people were just too tired to try to improve themselves.
You know,
it's funny that we owe,
you always talk about how you watch good and all that stuff.
If you really look into it,
you're a smart guy.
If you really look into the coca plant,
it started,
I was a mild hallucinogenic.
That kind of gave me a little bit of energy.
Yeah.
Well the,
the,
the people in high altitudes,
they chew the leaves,
the leaves and it's apparently it's healthy for you.
Eat all those guys.
I read some of those guys lived to 89 they work under the sun.
The altitude really high up there.
We,
it's us.
I'm destroyed this drug,
you know,
we put it into powder form and all this shit and what did they do?
How do they take it?
They take it out of the coca leaves and then they somehow or another hasn't
paid.
A white powder becomes a paste and then they put it on this fucking block.
I've never,
then you can't get that experience from the cocoa leaf.
Right?
You have to break it down to the White House.
I will tell you one charge.
I do know one thing I did blow with the eighties the late seventies and the blow
that some of the street,
now it's two complete different highs.
Yeah.
It was the 70s it was in the early eighties it was cocaine.
It wasn't processed.
There was no fillers though,
was no pink slime.
Right.
What I'm saying,
they was just made people feel great.
It was,
it was bro.
It didn't fucking make people lose their houses because it made them feel bad.
The problem with cocaine.
It was the marketing.
It wasn't cocaine that was so good.
We've discussed this.
The marketing was brilliant.
They gave it to people when a lot of money and musicians and athletes and they
gave people that we'll pour or mid 20 minutes of feeling important.
Oh my God,
these,
everybody was sniffing.
That's how a lot of athletes apparently get hooked after they stop,
stopped,
uh,
competing,
you know,
they miss a charge,
they missed something and then they'll start hanging around with people who
party and you know,
that's all a sudden now they're getting it out of a lot of boxers ended their
life that way.
Sonny Liston,
Sonny Liston ended his life that way.
A lot of guys did.
They,
uh,
they would just start doing drugs.
Uh,
Joe Lewis,
I'm pretty sure he started doing drugs.
The fucking spark is gone.
So you had official sparked and the artificial spark.
Isn't this good sugar Ray Leonard?
It's like Sylvia fucking sugar.
I mean,
there's a way out of problems putting on stockings and shit like that.
Do we get them coked up to,
I mean what I the trick when you're coked up to the gills.
Yeah.
I mean my Dick,
but I didn't take no pictures.
Everybody was saying that Oscar de la Hoya,
he's gay and I'm like,
no,
ask Adele.
He does coke.
I forgot about it just because he's weird.
He's hanging out with girls,
man.
Do you understand who's hanging out with these stupid hot Russian strippers and
he's,
he's coked out of his mind wearing women's clothes.
You refuse to believe that he was married.
He might be,
but an unbelief.
Been married for 10 years.
He's been fucking with a sheet on for seven.
He goes to New York and some Russian chicks puts a fucking,
that's your noble talking to his ass hole.
That's your gold.
We'll talk.
Turns the fucking lights out on yet you'll be waiting on line for toilet paper.
You know what I'm saying?
He fucking went bananas.
It just happens in our society.
And what are you going to do?
It's funny with Greg,
that night we were talking about what cocaine did,
you know would acid and pills.
Nobody wants that fucking house.
In the 70s you was hoping to join,
it was $2 all of a sudden cocaine came and people are losing their fucking
homes.
And so,
so you break it down.
The experience
that you get from chewing the leaves,
you can't get that cocaine rush.
You only get like a little mile buzz with chewing the leaves.
So the only way to get it into your bloodstream,
the way the cocaine was a massive dose dose.
I heard it's very good.
If you keep eating the fucking leaves,
you'll get high,
you know?
But you won't get high like coked up.
You have to eat like a whole salad.
You'll take the positive side of it.
I think you get like the euphoric without that fucking bullshit.
Just like a speed buds.
Yeah,
like that euphoria,
not even unhealthy for you.
It's really bizarre that that becomes cocaine,
which is like terrible for people I've sent,
you know,
we've all seen a lot of people have cocaine problems and it's a fucking
nightmare.
Yeah,
just terrible.
I had an ex girlfriend at a real real problem with it,
man.
She was scared.
She was scared that someone could bring it up at a party because she wouldn't be
able to say no,
they're the most annoying people.
It was when I first moved to La and,
uh,
the only thing I knew about,
cocaine was all negative from Boston.
And I had just gotten done being in the situation where I had to kind of get
away from a dude that I knew what it was selling it and he was dangerous and,
yeah.
Yeah.
And,
um,
so right when I came here and I started dating this chick and she was telling me
that she had this,
this cocaine thing,
like she,
she,
she liked it and she didn't like how much she liked it.
It made a really nervous and,
uh,
and I was like,
why?
And she's like,
well,
I could just see myself just completely fucking up my life for that stuff.
And I was like,
why didn't,
she was a very smart girl and she would,
uh,
if she would go to a party,
she said she would get scared if someone pulled it out.
She gets scared.
Hey Bro,
once some people get going to fucking go with apparently man,
especially girls,
I have a friend,
I don't,
I've never done coke.
Never.
But I have a friend who did it and started doing it just because the girls,
that's how he got into it because girls like it.
He said,
dude,
he goes,
girls would go crazy and when you do coke with him,
they'd go crazy.
So that's why he started doing it.
They don't like it.
They go fucking,
why is that?
Why you going to?
And if you get the perfect pigeon,
like you get the perfect one that just gets crazy by four o'clock.
What you whip up that second grant you built with,
they're walking around naked.
They're playing with that pussy.
They put coke rocks,
but it's fucking crazy.
And you see this and you're like,
wow,
how they suck dick.
How different it is.
The blow job.
I take it into it.
Don't fucking stop in mid suck and give me a number line to get some energy and
they'll suck that pipe for another 20 but it's that whole night.
You ain't going to come.
So how long have they suck your Dick for?
40 minutes and then they drink a beer and eat a sandwich and they're back on
that helmet.
Another 40 minutes.
You want to fucking smart,
you got to suck this fucking pipe.
Nothing coming out either.
So you basically given them a a bike,
you're shooting a blank on them for and an hour and a half sour fucking blank.
But they do get at the end,
it doesn't even shoot how it just drips down.
Get big.
Like why is it about her that keeps you from coming?
I don't fuck it though.
It's the Mecca.
I been one of the mechanisms,
I remember when I got locked up,
you know what you're waiting on line to go to the doctor.
Like once you get to prison,
they had all these things on a billboard,
like,
you know,
uh,
be careful of hepatitis B,
Shit like that.
Then they had newspaper articles on Coke and they had,
you know,
what the fuck and 80s people were shooting cocaine to the deck after like two
days.
They go,
fuck it.
What can I do to enhance this shit?
I've already lit her on fire.
I killed one hooker.
I've come 80 times.
I got a big bag of blow laughs.
Oh shoot it at my dick directly and their legs would go fucking like they'd have
to get rushed to the hospital.
They lose a leg.
You know you have a heart before Viagra and whatever the 80s people that deep
mind,
we're thinking that if you fucking put coke rocks and get Dick,
trust me.
I was one of them.
If I want to take,
if I would've been able to take me those,
I would have shot coca my day a couple of nights and Taco fucking coke bitch
crazy once record on her pussy.
Lick that shit.
And you tell them,
you show them that coke alone or you put that,
sprinkle it on their wall.
They go fucking crazy.
You lick that fucking clear until its mouth becomes no.
Yes mom,
that you put some money,
put some of Your pee hole.
You put a look.
Well I'd be hotel at business.
Suck it out.
It's all over.
Oh yeah.
Coke Rock in your pee.
Oh fuck.
Like you load it up like a spit ball,
right?
Like a spit balled like a challenge and then they suck it.
But the wetness of gets old Boomi or shit like that.
Okay,
so what is it about doing coke that makes people just become crazy?
Just makes me little freaky and makes people just,
what is the feelings?
I've never experienced it.
I don't want to know what the original,
the middle or the last result.
Any of the above because we get the beginning.
It's like getting laid for the first time.
If somebody opens paying and then you like it or you don't like a foreigner
song,
but what happens is socially,
socially,
once you do it,
it lifts you lips here to a different level of people.
Like you think that's how it gets you.
It's like anything else.
Joe Rogan,
gambling.
How did you get to talk?
More or less?
Said Doc,
I want to lift.
I want,
I never had biceps.
Doc.
Okay,
I want to shop.
That helped me get bicep.
What do you mean you shoot a fucking shot?
Next thing you know,
you've got to dissect your shoulders.
you've got the doctors every week shooting fucking steroids.
How does it start?
It all starts with beautiful.
It's like a marriage.
You're going to honeymoon.
They suck.
Get thick honey,
honey.
After a year of Monday night football,
you don't want to talk to them no more.
It's just like anything else.
It's beautiful.
At the beginning you're meeting people.
Oh my God,
that's so interesting.
It's called Cup to having art parties and shit.
I love that man.
It becomes something different.
Then it becomes taking the package home with you because at first you go out,
me and Brian.
Brian,
you got 20 yeah,
let's split a 40 boom,
we go on,
but at the end of the night,
see you tomorrow.
Bye.
Then it becomes something else.
Brian,
what do you,
let's get another 40 and go back to your house.
Let's get another four,
you know?
Then we go back to his house.
We get another 40 then it becomes so nice.
Not you're missing work.
You know,
you maggot Cowan is fucking down.
Now you're on a roll.
You know now you hookup up with a check that's completely out of your character.
Why?
Because you give her a rocket coke.
She licks your ass hall.
She likes your ball sack on fire.
She does.
There's nothing even emotional button that Joe Rogan,
there's no real,
you don't even like this chicken that day time,
but when you're doing coach,
she's fun.
She'll talk to you,
you know whatever.
A lot of guys like just the fact that a girl will go degenerate with them.
I'm sure nobody wants to go dock street.
They always take somebody down on the streets.
Then it becomes something like after 20 years with me,
it becomes creepy.
It hears,
it becomes,
it becomes your underlying motive for forever wake up in the moment when the
morning you think of that joke you thinking of going to tend to see you
tomorrow,
but I'm also thinking about how am I going to bring coke with me?
How much am I going to stay clean?
Am I going to get it tonight and double up for the week?
I just get really fucked up tonight.
That'll take me over till you start taking me over to when you say that,
like what?
What happened?
Like how many days could you go before you would get like a physical craving?
Three,
three days.
Those days.
Three.
Four.
I got a craving every night at 8:00 AM eight o'clock my fucking ears would go
numb.
Like Michael Corleone and the Godfather.
We shots a lot.
So you know what I'm saying is go numb and I couldn't,
but I was,
I was thinking about it,
the Ed that you know,
he used to run red lights until I got to the ATM machine.
What?
Even while I was taking the money out of the ATM machine.
How was it different person?
There was no logic.
It's like that joke you'd do about sitting in the back of the bus and the bus
drivers,
you Dick,
you know like I had no logic.
Even if God was right there,
Saint Joe,
you're 400 pounds,
you're going to die.
I had no logic that whole drive.
I had no logic to.
I would make the u turn on sunset.
No logic,
make a right on the brass,
shoot right over to Dante and get the package and I'm the drive.
I'd be cracked.
Now I'd stop for Red Lights now I got my focus back now I would because I needed
a red light to break it up,
so I would break it up right there,
right there when Rachel,
because it comes with a rock and I would pick it up and my hand in the Baggie.
So like you've put your fingers inside the mountain or on the outside of the
Baggie and breaking from the crush it crush it.
If it's,
if it's a rerock coke then it's hard.
Then it's a full Gacy.
You've got to get the hammer up,
but it's real coke.
It's soft.
It should break first fucking and then you just put a dollar building.
How you can tell he's good.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But it's really hard to get real coke.
Sure.
We caught it and they put speed in it and it was an amazing,
if you,
that's what deregulation is,
ladies and gentlemen.
When when needed,
we don't regulate something and you make it illegal.
Then a bunch of different people allowed to cut it up and do whatever the fuck
they want to do with it and call it [inaudible] accident.
You couldn't do this.
It would all be completely illegal if it was being sold at cvs.
You know,
if you could set up by it at the liquor store,
if I could just buy a leaf.
I wonder if like regular cocaine,
how bad his regular cocaine for you without all the shit.
Is it just as addictive?
Target's kind of be like anything else.
Chinese food is good for you one time every two weeks,
but if you do regular full gang can be good for him.
I'm sure that if,
I'm sure if this society,
there's a coke feed scientist somewhere that could find one positive effect of
you and I both thought I pay one positive effect that has for me while I was
doing it.
I wasn't a no more really,
it's amazing.
You focus on fucking shadows.
I was good at math.
I would love to do math equations when I was coked up really at my fuck.
You know,
I'm not a mind fuck or you know,
you have to be and go,
what a fan.
This is Silva for Muhammad Ali.
Go Fuck your mother.
I ain't got time to puzzle out.
I got more important things like a joker,
you know,
but mine fuck yourself.
Like what if I went on the road every week,
make 10 grand and sole 300 tee shirts.
I would do shit like that.
Like an,
you know like shit like that.
Like a do math like that for hours.
Like it's got nothing to do with me but I was get so analytical you'd get so
analytical.
I think about shit,
but I was thinking about and break it down.
The same thing that you do with acid you can do with mushrooms.
You know when you,
when you take a mushroom,
if you're a normal fucking individual,
if you have some type of pain going on in your heart right now after an hour and
giggling and joking around that page and start to come up because it's forcing
you to deal with it.
That's where the bad trip comes in.
And it's the same thing.
Probably happens for coke.
It happens for heroin.
I mean dog everything.
You know,
if I do two squatch twice a week,
that's great for you.
If I do it six times a week with 400 pounds,
I'm a fuck something up.
Eventually everything.
Joe Rogan,
you know,
does the,
but the coke experience is very different than the Coke Cup would speed
experience.
Right.
Coke experience I had in the 80s and the coke experience I had five years ago is
two different things.
When did it,
I mean there's no way to tell like until you do it any way.
I think the cold chains in mid 80 [inaudible] when they figured out that the
speed aspect of it,
we'd get you addicted.
Well they figured out the cause.
So you get addicted to the speed.
You're not even getting into the tokens much gives you wings.
Whoa.
That is crazy.
Once they started throwing the speed and the accelerants in there,
you know,
crack is he coke was,
coke was a loser for a while because they couldn't smoke.
The Bush administration couldn't.
Bush.
They weren't letting an ether into the,
that was the biggest problem.
It wasn't getting,
we've had this discussion.
Yeah,
yeah.
You couldn't get it out.
So they,
they,
they started washing it with gasoline so that coke had a horrible smell to it.
Like you do a line and go,
Jesus Christ.
Like some of it was like,
I remember one time I went and bought a bad buy.
I bought nine ounces.
The coke was tremendous,
but it smells like cat piss.
And I would sell it at bargain prices and people would still come back.
Like,
Joey,
I love you,
but this is brutal dog.
This is pure cat,
your campus.
I ended up snowing the whole thing and that like,
so I burned holes.
I've been here.
You don't have football players put those black marks or their eyes.
I had to big takes at the here from the fucking whatever was coming out was just
burning my fucking skin.
Oh my fucking,
it was free.
I had already paid for it.
I didn't know that you,
you know what?
A lot of cocaine became a no loser because of the coke was good.
You sold it at high prices and if it tastes like a monkey's ass,
then you turning it into crack and a bird,
all the residue and it gave you back the pure cocaine.
That's crazy.
What a w who the fuck figured that out?
That two black guys in Harlem.
So you follow up saying this is what our conversation,
you know?
No,
no black guy.
Brian,
no black guy or no fucking coke fiends.
And we call them and go,
listen Brian,
we've got 40 hours worth of coke.
I'm sick and tired of the snow on it.
What if we put it in a glass and we put baking soda and we put it in a microwave
oven and cook it up and in 20 seconds,
what does that bell goes?
B,
we take it out,
we smoke it.
Two white guys on COPD in the event that the them creating crack,
what is it?
Why is the,
what does the baking soda I have to do with anything because it cleans baking
soda.
Like when you put in your refrigerator,
you could put it in do,
she's fucking,
you could brush your fucking teeth when it beat it.
Beat got bought out or become whatever's in there.
It neutralizes,
it burns away all the waste.
So all the shit they put in there,
like if you put a gram of cocaine and you get after you take it out way that
motherfucker again,
you get six tenths.
Now is that crack or is that free base?
That's like a free base.
But you could take that,
that thing and put it into cigarettes.
A lot of Colombians would just take the front of the cigarettes out in,
pop those in the clubs.
And you'd think that smoking a cigarette that's smoking pure fucking bazooka
isn't,
I'm saying things.
So that takes a killing the cancer.
Wow.
So what is the difference then between crack and freebase?
What does it,
how does they did something with craft to multiply it even more to make it more
addictive?
No,
no.
It can make it more to make more,
make more money from it.
It was really cheap.
Yeah.
Because I can understand that cocaine was,
I thought that's what it was in that spirit and I'm like,
no,
that's the shit together.
Shit,
the shit they do basically they put it up in a paint thing with thinner and you
know like let's say,
I don't even know what,
what you got 28 grams in an ounce,
so 16 ounces times 28 whatever that is.
A regular coke or a regular person would throw a 10 on 28 so you would throw 16
times 10 160 grams a cut on it or something.
This is what I'm just assuming we're crack.
You could probably throw grand for grant,
so I could probably get whatever the result is with 28 times 16 and add it and
neutralize it.
The 50% and I'll get,
you know,
with heroin,
what happened with the mob d do nothing to hit everybody.
So Bob [inaudible] fucking morons.
They just figured out how to take heroin and pay 50,000 and get a 400,000 back
from it to magic that I,
if I figured out how to give you 50 grand every and on Friday,
I picked up 400,000.
Wow.
How are they doing that?
Because they would take an hour with it,
cutting it to knock to do you seem like an American gangster?
The cops are taking the heroin,
cutting it and selling it back to the mob.
The mob was cutting itself.
This is fucking craziness.
This is the Alex Jones talks about,
they were just taking heroin even at 40%.
Oh fuck your world.
Doesn't it amazing when you find out how many cops actually have sold drugs and
being caught by it?
Remember the cocaine cowboys with the whole entire one entire graduating class
of the Miami Police Department,
the uh,
the whatever it is,
the,
uh,
what's the,
not the,
um,
what is it?
The training of the school?
Yeah.
Police Academy.
100.
100% of them either were murdered or wound up being incarcerated for being
corrupt.
While she put your sentiment,
but what happened at that time was Miami got a gun put to the head like any
other,
any other community spics moving Latino's wherever you were.
Cubans were everywhere in 1979 you know,
Fidel said fucking 98 boats filled with Cubans and maybe four of them stayed in
Miami.
How much it was cocaine responsible for what Miami became,
Oh my God,
it was built on it.
This is Copeland's.
Grover.
I'm going to had an investigative were bill Curtis coconut grow was a place
where pirates used to hang on the 1700 great story where I'm going and that
whole city is built on cocaine.
I know construction who lived down there for a while and he told me,
I don't know if this is a verifiable fact,
but there's more banks per capita in Miami than any other city in the country.
It makes sense.
[inaudible]
money and bringing in cocaine.
So in the 80s would that thing when I with those cops,
the city got to go put their their head.
They're like,
Bro,
you got all these Latinos and you got to know Latins on the police force.
You've got to put more cops or the police force in a hurry.
Jesus,
before it gets out of hand.
So they even do background checks.
Oh my God.
They sealed all that Juvi records and they hide all these cops.
They had full cops,
right?
Wake up.
That would just pull you over taking your drugs with drawing you into the river.
That's what they call the river cops.
There are cops.
I remember being Joe in coconut grove the week one of them got let out of jail.
He got a job as a cook and the whole community signed petitions to not,
it was at a cafe called Mambo down there not to be hired and the community
because he killed them.
What your fucking people.
I mean,
they weren't like killing people because they did something wrong to them.
They would just pull you over shooting you and throwing you into the fucking
river.
How did he get out of jail?
How that policy did that time?
Whoa,
that's silly.
Murderer.
They got arrested.
They got arrested in 85 and they were walking the streets and how many people
did they killed though?
Then you should be dead.
I don't know.
You've got to look to tell a bunch of people.
You're dead.
You don't get out of jail.
That's ridiculous.
That's nonsense.
I'm liberal about a lot of shit.
I'm liberal,
black,
gay marriage,
but about that you can suck my dick.
That guy needs to be done.
The system has loopholes.
You know reality.
Let's say he did 14 fucking years.
It's like that's what it is.
They gave him a 30 year fucking sentence or a 20 year sentence.
They give you a 20th since you'd do 10 and then you all in front of the parole
board.
The Parole Board votes on you to get out in the street or done in a violent
offense.
If that's true,
why is the Manson released?
Because who the fuck is my release?
This guy goes in front of the parole board and we actually offer a Nazi thing on
his forehead.
Where are you going to?
Who's going to hire?
That's fucking guy.
Who's going to hire him?
What?
What social security benefit that z fucking have that guy.
Yeah,
he was awesome.
What?
What are you gonna do?
I am your Jesus.
He made me man,
has it off your garbage and leave it in your streets,
man.
Who's a spooky,
that's a good guy to be a sales,
but all those bitches at the shoot shoot.
Oh by the way,
people don't even realize that he didn't kill anybody.
He might've killed one guy,
but almost everybody in that whole organization was killed by that Tex Watson
Guy who went on to yeah.
And the squeaky Fromme who tried to kill president.
Forward word.
I had a dog named squeaky Fromme who wound up killing one of my other dogs.
Oh yes.
Wiki.
Yeah.
That crazy bitch.
That last name.
I screen crazy dogs.
Yeah.
That whole Manson thing was a trip because he didn't even really kill anybody.
Man.
Those those other people killed people for when I text Watson Guy and that Tex
Watson guy became like a serious born again Christian while he's in the hole,
you know,
it's probably the only way he could ever rationalize his situation and where
he's going.
I mean,
what he did murder those people.
They cut a baby out of a woman's body.
You know,
that's what made supposedly made Roman Polanski crazy.
That was his wife or his,
uh,
his girl,
I dunno if it were married,
I think it was his wife,
but she had,
uh,
his,
his baby inside of her and the fucking Manson fan that came and cut her out.
I mean,
it's really,
it's a really sick shit man.
It's,
the whole thing is really sick.
I mean,
they wrote,
wrote shit on the walls and stuff and you know,
it's like really,
it's,
it's a scary,
scary dark proposition that some little crazy psychopath was able to talk these
people and to just committing just horrible murders for him.
Some sick fuck.
Figured out a way to control these people and get all these lost people together
and just unleashed them,
you know?
And they were all family.
Like what a crazy fucking thing that must've been mad.
Could you imagine?
First of all,
Charles Manson could never existed without,
with Google.
That shit will never work because he would have been talking crazy shit.
And girls who have been pulling out their phones going,
wait a minute.
No,
that's not true.
You know,
this is how it's done to the government set up this way.
The North,
the congress controls this,
but back then he could say anything.
You know,
he was just a charismatic guy and they were looking for guidance.
Next thing you know,
Charlie Manson's to fucking daddy of the family.
You know what?
It's weird,
crazy little wild.
Ex Con is the,
the leader of this group of fucking psychopaths.
They're running around cutting people up and that sort of symbolized for a lot
of people what was wrong with the sixties that's it symbolized for a lot of
people what was wrong with the drug culture and the hippies that there was
amongst them,
there were,
they weren't all altruistic.
There's a lot of hippies that were just fucking crazy and drug use had to be
stopped because some people just couldn't take it.
Look at the manse of family and that was like a good,
you know,
reason for justification like that though.
Those that one group of fucking crazy assholes ruined it for a lot of people
talk,
but you can't blame it all on drugs now.
He can't.
It was a bunch of kids.
It's like we sit here every week and you know,
how do people get caught up in a cult?
How do people
get brought up in gangs?
My friend's parents were in Mexico going to school at White,
couple from Michigan,
educated good families,
went to Mexico,
got talked into moving to Pennsylvania and moving into a cult and they started
having kids with the Kalita.
Oh,
the guy who started fucking the wife.
when does it hold?
Do you have in your soul when your,
your,
your DNA that you allow that into you and that's any cult,
whether it's Jim Jones,
whether it took religious sector,
we're all looking for a hole to fill.
Well,
I got fucking hole that they had to go kill fucking people at night because some
guy sent them,
I mean,
it's a bunch of people that were confused that ran into a fucking salesman.
When people run into a salesman,
it's a bad fucking day fee.
They ran into a soundbite again,
the guy might have killed one fucking person.
I kill it.
No pill is Joe Rogan.
I see him stab somebody first and give me the knife.
I'm stabbed cause we're all going down here and you're going to send me to go I
some fucking guy because the Lord said,
you know Dave Koresh,
you know these people fill a void.
Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
it's not the drugs.
The drugs accelerates the fucking weakness to a point because they'll confuse,
now they're fucking confused.
Even though I was essentially in a cult because I was in,
when you're doing martial arts,
it's positive cult when,
but you get involved in something like taekwondo.
One of the great things about it is it teaches you discipline and respect for
your higher ranks and all this stuff.
But in reality it's just weird.
It's like this.
I mean it's all this really controlled environment where you,
you know,
the,
the masters there and Oh mastercam and you have to bow to the master.
And you know,
the younger students,
they bow to you and everyone's in line and everything is,
yes sir.
Yes sir.
I mean if you,
it's all positive and you learn a lot from,
don't get me wrong,
I mean it,
it greatly enhanced,
enhanced my life.
Martial arts completely changed who I am.
But when you looked at it,
there's a lot of culty shit to it.
You know,
it's not like Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
the instructors,
they,
they get respect more just by rolling with people and explaining techniques and
by the reputation is that they don't have to go in and,
and everybody bow and everybody bows in class and lines up and turn.
It's ever very militaristic.
You know,
we would bow to the flag and bowed to the instructor and key eye and you know,
and everything would be,
everything would be done,
you know,
like this intensity and focus.
Okay,
what do you want?
And I just got to ask them so I won't keep talking about as something bro.
But you know,
jot,
it's very culty.
It's,
it's a good thing.
It was a great thing for me,
but it could be abused.
And I knew it was abused now with my school,
but I saw with other schools it was always,
there was always scandals.
Like an instructor was did something fucked up or one guy in the crowd,
we are talking about a fucking charger.
This guy's got every charging for what do you need?
That's why I was asking you why uh,
iPhone works.
No,
you kind of a thousand fucking,
why can't it go iPhone Simon resistance prints got the iPhone I three I liked
that.
I liked that.
Uh,
you look at it,
it's kind of cold is a called age,
you know,
it was a very positive call it,
but it's very positive.
But I was very lucky that the cult that I had,
not only did they not take advantage of me and doing anything negative to me,
but in fact they enhanced me.
They taught me a lot of discipline and they gave me a job and they gave me like
construction free.
Like I trained at a place called the Jay,
Jay Hahn,
Tim Taekwondo Institute in Boston.
And so one of the best experiences of my life,
when I say it's a cult,
I in no way mean that anything negative happened to me because of it.
It was only positive but we were in a really good school.
We were like one of the best schools in the country we we saw and it was
everything was done the way it was supposed to be.
Everything was done with like real serious and he said it was a top class
taekwondo school but there was a lot of other karate schools and taekwondo
schools that were in the martial arts community.
We watched like big scandals happen and it was a lot of it was because people
would get into that position of power and they would start abusing it because
everybody treated their,
their seafood there,
sensei there,
whoever it was,
they treated them like they were a god and there was a lot of like sex scandals
would happen in martial arts schools.
It was like super common.
You know,
one guy got in trouble,
really famous guy got in trouble for having sex with some 17 year old girl and
it became like a big statutory rape thing.
It was like real common that people like it completely enamored by their
instructors.
It's one of the reasons why and a lot of those arts,
the instructors like wanted to keep everyone down and scan.
They had to be almost invincible in your eyes because otherwise you're moving up
the ladder and if you are you the top black belt in the school then in the
instructor is the only guy that it's left that you're really not really sparring
with.
You know,
how do you think you'd do with him?
He hasn't really sparked with anybody,
man,
what does this timing like even,
you know,
can I,
can I beat that guy?
And you start thinking those things you never think that way about your
instructor in,
in a proper school setting because the,
the,
the seniors and the,
the upper ranks in your instructor,
they become like,
they become a father figure.
They become like a,
you know,
a,
a king,
you know,
becomes like,
it's very important to give in to their,
you know,
their,
uh,
their order,
you know,
and he called him Sir all the time.
It's very culty,
but it's really good for you.
You know what this country does not remember you because you were young man.
I'm an old man.
I was alive before Bruce Lee died.
I was alive.
I was,
I was dressed.
When did he die?
[inaudible] 73 but I was part of
that walking around with a cup full suit on and goal to Chinatown and burning
incense in the house and eat rice with chopsticks.
And my mum was like,
are you fucking serious?
Are you fucking crazy?
And I remember when he died,
the sad,
like people couldn't believe it.
It was like John Lennon fucking die.
And what happened after that with martial arts?
You know,
when I was a kid,
I went to,
uh,
Lauren Joe's father realized your whatever.
And that was a score on 98th and west end that was always school for miles guy.
He's talking about [inaudible] and all of a sudden martial arts blew up like cut
karate schools and the 60s and this country will
then five fingers of death came out,
you know the Chinese connection until I drag and that were way before cause he
died rather the movie got released.
But a year before the enter the dragon came up.
You know,
black guys would lose their mind.
They will probably come full suits,
white guy,
everybody who had bruised elbows because everybody had new trucks.
You,
we've had bruises on the back of your fucking neck or because you know you'll
have to do,
we Corrado the Hong Kong cat came out,
he had new chucks and he would put copper tubes at the end for plumbing and
that's when people were really fucking starting to hurt themselves.
That was around 74 at the Bruce Lee died that everybody started taking out.
Bruce Lee stepped aside,
Bruce Lee and make way for Colorado,
the Hong Kong cat.
All that shit started,
but I was here in this country and what happened?
So people thought it was a fucking savior.
Like,
finally,
I didn't learn how to fight.
Finally,
I can learn confidence and let me tell you something.
It only becomes a cult.
When you walk out that door thinking you're invincible.
That's when it becomes a cult and you've seen it.
Those types of those schools,
and I see it happening to girls,
they get caught up.
Something bad happens.
They go in there and by the time they were purple belt,
they're like,
I could actually take a fucking guy.
Oh,
they get crazy and go,
well,
there's a lot of,
a lot of women,
I think,
especially in Jujitsu,
that purple belts,
it probably could take all that good so I can take you.
I'm not saying
it becomes a coat when I go out there and go,
you know what?
I'm going to go to a white castle at two in the morning.
I'm going to take out four mother fuckers.
That's when it becomes a cult.
I don't want you to ever think that your experience a little bit more than most
people would striking and stuff like that,
but I never want you to think it's really a Kung Fu move where you're going to
want to uh,
Steven Seagal shit people,
man.
People stab people.
You get hit with a chair and the head goodnight.
Ooh.
Oh no more.
I'm,
yeah,
he's a motherfucker.
Yeah,
he takes a stick out.
That's not what the class by the one,
by the way,
everybody's doing that.
90% of those things happen because someone's trying to prove something and if
you didn't,
if you just like assessed the situation and instead of thinking,
oh,
I'm going to prove this motherfucker,
man,
this motherfucker,
what's up?
Instead of doing that,
just think smart.
You just get out of there.
What if this,
if these were hyenas,
would you stay?
Now they're Schuman.
Hyenas get out of there.
You're in a situation.
Whenever you're in a situation,
if it can possibly be avoided that you don't fight,
don't fight.
The last thing I want to do is open up that door to negativity.
You know,
you beat someone physically,
first of all,
they beat you.
It's horrific and it you're at their mercy by though.
And that could happen
with Maza Gotti and Joe,
whatever's gonna come out.
Some people I've known a lot of thought they were absolutely,
Oh God,
they were absolutely invincible.
They did stand up to anybody.
Nobody could talk shit to them.
Then they get the fuck beat out of them one night,
you know,
you might fuck up and all of a sudden,
you get in a fight and you don't know that this kid is like a state champion
wrestler and he picks you up the air and dumps you on your fucking head on the
concrete and you're fucked up for a long time.
I mean,
guys can die from that shit.
He could punch you.
I mean,
who knows how merciful this guy is.
He might start punching your fucking face and while you're unconscious and you
can't do shit,
imagine that waken up to multiple concussions and your nose exploding on your
face and you're not even waking up.
He just just shocks of images.
Your body can even move cause this fucking gorilla is pounding your face into a
pancake.
That's all really possible,
man.
You know why you just see stupid fighting is stupid.
You know I used to see,
unless you want to do it for a living,
you know where he's to see a lot of people get knocked off the Jersey shore.
Oh yeah.
The Jersey shore.
I used to see,
watch the fights were those just sit.
There you
go.
That TV show or I wonder what it's like now.
But when we used to go down there and do Bob Gonzo gigs,
Holy Shit.
That place was wild.
Jersey shore is wild.
It's like a beach community.
But of all savages,
it's like 90% savages.
Spi side's fees.
I Paul,
when we walked in Ireland,
uh,
we have no idea Brian.
It's a fucking blast.
But now the wild oh beaches are packed.
Bumper to bumper,
you got people on top of you.
People put makeup on it.
It's like everybody's fucking kip could dash.
You have to go to the fucking beach.
Well they don't understand.
They see a show like Jersey shore and they are baffled.
They're baffled like how were these motherfuckers on TV and whatnot?
What the fuck is going on?
One more interesting guys.
So everybody's trying to,
you know,
find their angle in.
It's,
it's,
I mean,
and I don't blame them shit man.
If I lived there,
I'd probably be trying to do the exact same thing.
You know,
why not?
Shit.
You see these people,
all of a sudden they're making millions of dollars and they're essentially doing
the same shit you do and you've got to work a whole day.
That's preposterous.
You know,
to them it must be like mind boggling.
Smokey must blow all disease.
Must be,
it's a lot of hot bitches and Jersey that would just attack Snookie if they ever
saw her.
They like feel it,
that girl stealing from them,
you know,
like how is this fucking girl?
She thinks she's hot.
Oh my God,
she's fucking hot and now she's pregnant.
Who fucked her?
Who?
Fac Tech.
If they saw me,
if the fucking producers and met me for sure I'd be on that show.
What should I be on that show?
That fucking angry Jersey fucking squawky girl,
angry calling girl type.
Is that the most unattractive?
It's a combination between the angry Italian girl from Boston and the angry
Italian girl from Jersey that that's very specific.
Squawky sort of violence threatening
the Pisa has anybody that don't even look good.
There's a lot of complaining going on or Scada complaining.
Some girls even when you know,
it gets to the point where we're actually having,
you know like if,
if you,
if you tried to get to a relationship with them,
you start dating now,
go out with them a few times,
get closer cause girls or is this going to be this?
Like sometimes you got to wonder is this going to be worth it?
Like what's going on here?
Like someone before you,
before you actually have sex with them,
they're like holding it over you.
Like it's this reward that one day will take place if you do.
Exactly as I say.
And those girls would scare the shit out of me.
Like why are you so controlling and crazy bitch and we like each other or not.
Could you imagine this Jersey shore?
If we had to live in the middle of that,
me,
you and Joey Diaz,
a two bedroom apartment and we had to go in the middle of the legal work at the
nightclub that's next door.
All three of us had to do it for a year.
Wow.
What it would be an experiment we would call first death squad goes to the
Jersey shore.
I'll go crazy.
I might be able to teach them.
She was shit.
Those kids,
those kids are fucking crazy seminars with those kids all day.
They teach them about eating.
We'd,
it was for real bro.
Teach them about yoga earlier with the beat.
Those girls,
those guys eat.
Start to judge that you would start wearing Dan.
It's all the shoot.
They look twice a week.
They lift twice a week into legitimate,
amazing.
Give him some free Jujitsu lessons.
Show him some shit about how the country really works.
Get them to eat.
We'd have you ever change them.
We can turn them around.
Have you ever worn a Bandana like on your head?
Like did like Bruce Springsteen?
Yeah,
I probably tried it once or twice.
It's a,
I think I tried it once at the gym cause a lot of dudes are wearing them at the
gym that's bringing it back.
But it's really stupid because it just slides off cause I'm expressive.
So I moved my a forehand a lot and it just slides up and then it falls off your
head.
We should make a stretchy band Nana.
That's like comfortable.
I've always had it accessories for guys though.
I like wallet chains,
chain
function.
Talking about like fucking people get dressed up to go to the gym or the beach
and they write the accessories like back at the fuck.
If I see it hot chicken in the hat and the pony tail is going through the day.
It's to plan.
Well we're east coast.
Anybody that tries too hard,
it was always a Douche bag and he guide shows up at the beach with a fucking
paradigm shoulder.
What are you doing asshole?
You know who are you?
You know guys walking through the park with a snake.
I don't mean this is my pet snake.
Whoa.
Can I touch it?
Who are you?
You fucking Weirdo.
You know what I mean?
Like when someone tried really hard to be eccentric,
it's always like,
can't they'll fuck with your cowboy hat?
You're from Pennsylvania.
They put glasses on.
I'll tell you what my pet peeves are with somebody who wears glasses to look
different.
Yeah.
How about glasses that are real?
Remember that?
That was a trend for a while.
They drive me crazy and people like that grow up all over sudden down.
They play golf.
Come here,
but I put my dick in your fucking nose study.
You want to go play fucking the golf?
It's supposed to be fun.
And what's wrong with that?
I just don't like you.
You off from where you're from what I'm saying?
Yeah,
but I know people from everywhere.
Play Golf.
No,
just do it.
Just to fit.
It is a weird thing how there's a lot of people that do that.
I've,
I've had a lot of people ask me if I play golf because they wanted to have
meetings with me on a golf course and I was like,
wow,
no,
nope.
None of that.
But he can't say,
can you play pool?
Cause no,
not in as many people play pool.
Not even though they look at you like fucking you're not part of our club.
Yeah,
I know.
You don't want to play in the skull and bones,
God your society.
You don't want to play a hundred bucks to walk around and fucking 18 get the
fuck out of here.
Walking around in the fucking park lot.
Hit a pigeon.
I know a place that's a golf course.
It's a country club and it cost a quarter million dollars to join just a quarter
million dollars just to join.
And then you have to pay yearly dues,
but just to get it and you have to give them a quarter of a million dollars for
the rights to use this stupid fucking told the judges just kind of chunk of
land.
But think about how to calm that is how many members must these motherfuckers
see you at the club on sub day?
So to keep anybody out that's not just stupid rich,
it's all just Maza Rodney's and Ferrari's and Porsche's.
And it's a weird place to drive by because you're like,
what a weird slice of the world right there.
That's a like an Uber.
Uber 1% they fucked themselves cause ludicrous joins to call it.
That's what it's all over.
But the shock because they say they all get together.
Go.
We don't know.
Charge them to live.
I don't know.
Raise the price to half a million.
That motherfucker shows up with three quarters of the mill.
There was a crazy baseball player.
Then I actually just got kicked out of Lake Sherwood,
some a athlete pro athlete was living there and that's another place that Lake
Sherwood Country Club is another one of those.
Let me find that in your head.
What's up?
B makes up 20 fucking charges.
You got to go try just for younger Joey,
you have like some stupid kind of phone man.
You gotta get up.
Get yourself an iPhone four g perfect uncle Joey.
I don't need a cab.
They don't even know what it is.
I don't want to fucking doc talk to nobody.
He was rocking that Forgy and been in and out.
It's beautiful.
I think he's a baseball player.
Hold on a second.
Dykstra,
what does is Lenny Dykstra?
No,
he's not.
That's the guy who's going to jump,
right?
Yeah.
What did he do?
He was like Robin cars or something.
What did the fucking,
do you know what happened to have grown mental illness?
Really?
He,
I think he's crazy.
You see that 60 minutes or the HBO thing.
He's fucking crazy and I met him and he was a decent type of guy.
You know?
I've met above the best dance boy.
He was.
Okay.
Then he had the cloudwatch was lunch Dykstra.
He was the one who was kicked out.
Oh please.
Lenny Dykstra did a thousand and whatnot.
His son's date.
The,
the chicken was surprise.
I see that today.
Rarely.
Yeah.
It's crazy,
bro.
Really Dicey is crazy.
Yes.
What did he do?
Like what was his scam to try to steal cars?
What were they doing?
I don't,
how do you go from being like a walking?
No,
but world renowned baseball player to be a guy who steals cars,
whole thing.
I just know that he went bad and a bunch of people with 60 minutes or was an
HBO,
the Docu thing,
other but a real sports and he was hysterical.
I was like,
got it.
He was like,
ah,
you know,
sorry,
you broke right now.
And he went in his pocket or her fucking broke,
what?
You owe millions.
Fuck up,
fuck my life.
And he was,
you know,
I mean,
you can't do that.
So now they're going at him for everything and they're going to get,
right now he's in a downward spiral.
Right?
It's not only are they watching him,
but on top of that,
he's giving them something to do and now he's trying to rob from Peter to pay
Paul.
You know,
just trying to do what anybody would do and,
and that fucking thing,
you're gonna make mistakes and he's going to be a worst shape.
Any,
well,
what did he do?
He went to the car and tried to sell it.
He did something crazy.
I don't know what the fuck he did.
I mean,
it's just instead of coke thing is that,
is that what happens?
Because there is there drugs involved.
When guys started making terrible decisions,
I take with desperation,
get crazy.
It's just crazy.
If you see the interview on Hbo,
Real Sports,
you'll go,
there's something wrong.
They guys,
where would you give him a load for fucking $2 million.
This guy,
the plane he was flying around,
he would go for Bali with the collar bosses in a plane,
bitch.
Wow.
You know what I mean?
This guy was crazy butlers and Austin,
he lost her.
He was living in his house.
They took the furniture.
I took everything.
Wow.
But I do remember that when he went in his pocket,
he had hit the fucking thing and he's like,
I'm not broke bitch.
Check this out.
You want your money?
Come get it.
Very coke heavy episode we got going on here.
But you know it's gotta be hard.
Like I heard Chris talk has been out,
you know that he's been what out every night he goes to the Haha the Improv,
the comedy store.
Every night out's good.
Eight guys doing comedy and he's up there talking cause he doing well.
He's doing well.
But people are asking them like,
why you must fucking onstage?
He goes,
cause $20 million ain't shit.
He goes at the end of the fucker when he goes,
I thought I had 200 million.
He's been telling the story late in the onstage.
He goes,
I'm broke.
It's called the government shit.
Once they come get their ass and a lot of these people bro Spam and they don't
realize that Uncle Sam Spock and watch it,
you got to give half of that doe coming in,
but you don't know and when you're black,
let's face it,
when you're renting thing,
Joe Rogan people,
you're,
you're lost relatives start calling
this guy and that guy and the money goes fast,
Bro.
You know what's going on with Gallagher right down.
Andrews had a gang heart attack and he just decided he's retiring no more.
Go on the road.
He's like,
I'll give them the banks of houses.
I can't pay for these houses because he's doing like this little comedy clubs
just to stay alive because I would've thought that Gallagher would have been
able to draw more than that.
I don't understand.
That doesn't make sense to me that he has to do these tiny little children.
I was 20 years ago pro,
but I would think it's still just for the variety of it.
Look,
he was not,
it wasn't the best show in the world,
but it was ridiculous.
It was a fun thing to do,
you know,
go see,
move on.
Shame on him for still taking it to that point for this.
Depending on fruit house payments are little things that other people don't plan
ahead.
Did you ever hear him on the Mark Marin show?
No,
I just heard it this week and uh,
I actually heard a clip of it off of Youtube.
I heard when he,
uh,
he left and as it's fucking remarkable.
It's really crazy.
You know,
like a lot of people
give mark Marin a hard time for,
uh,
his interview style and you know,
and for causing,
you know,
uncomfortable moments with people.
But this shit wasn't him at all.
This guy is crazy.
He didn't hassle.
Oh my God,
Dude.
First of all,
what he was talking about comics,
you know,
like saying what they should and shouldn't do.
You know the,
you shouldn't talk about yourself on stage,
you know like nobody wants to hear that.
And Marin was like,
what are you talking about?
Like what if you have something entertaining to to say on stage like that,
that some other than that makes you less of a comic.
Like it was preposterous.
Your life was very different.
He said it was saying shit like you can never work a state fair.
And you know in Marin was like who the fuck wants to work at State Fair?
Like what a weird thing to say.
But that's really what he was saying.
I mean he was really saying that if you,
you don't,
you,
you don't do your comedy for everybody,
you'll never be able to work at state fair.
You should do it the way I'm doing it.
And he's seen.
So you're dismissing a great deal of rug,
really highly respected performers and galleries.
Like they're doing it wrong.
Is that deck.
It was crazy.
I saw him making fun of a guy with,
I think we've talked about it.
Yeah.
Cerebral Palsy or something.
I can't remember what he had is where,
I mean he's,
yeah,
I don't,
can't walk right and stuff.
And he made fun of them.
I don't know what it is or why,
why he's like that was huge.
And his brother tried to rob him when he gave his brother is he gave his brother
go the whole fucking either sold it to him or something and his brother looked
just like him.
So it was an easy sell.
And then he decided to come back and when he decided to come back then he wanted
his brother to stop and then it became like a real problem.
So then it was Gallagher and Gallagher too.
You know like his brother was like,
a lot of people thought they were going to see Gallagher.
I mean he was essentially doing the same act,
which is really kind of fucking creepy.
It's like some invasion of the body snatchers type shit.
All of a sudden your brothers like taking over your life,
your brother's on the road doing your jokes,
you know,
he has access to all of your material from your 14 one hour specials.
And I guess like they made some sort of a business deal,
but after a while,
I forgot what I was going to tell you.
I quit this shit.
The cookie.
I knew Joey did something because before the podcast even started,
he's,
he's the one who put the joint await the quickest.
No,
I ate a little piece of a bank.
Chocolate.
Those bank chocolates.
Triple strength.
The Hash.
Yeah.
You're,
you will generally will look like their sandbags right now.
Oh yeah.
I'm pretty fucked up man.
I'm saying
it must be amazing.
I'd be,
I heard you say something to somebody at the store one time and it was,
it made sense or ah,
the guy,
the guy from Oakland,
the big guy that had to show about the school teacher,
big guys hanging out,
Mr. Cooper.
Oh yeah.
You want him,
we're having a conversation with neighbor next door and he said,
Mark Curry says awesome dude.
By the way,
he said to you,
you never buy,
motherfuckers don't know that you don't buy none to the fourth season.
Yeah,
he did say that.
Or You said it.
Somebody said,
you don't buy something to the fourth season and what happens to you?
You make a little bit of scratch ban and it goes,
you know,
Joe,
even if your financial,
you,
your house is paid for that exist.
You still got to pay for that.
And it was from the estate tax is still big.
You have to make money.
$3 million house,
you still got to make money if pay those fucking taxes and you know what the
road,
they caught it and you know,
Joe,
you will watch VH one.
Like where are they now?
You're gonna get stuck.
You smoking dope in the afternoon and they show like Cherry Pie,
right?
Hey,
you know,
he just died.
He died out here at the hotel.
Not out here.
He was in,
um,
I think it was in West hills or woodland.
Hit right around here.
So yeah,
like the,
like one of those weird hotels that are like right off of the one on one man,
I'm just giving you an example.
10 miles away from here.
He's got right one,
don't show last.
They'll show like a one of those bands like eight six,
seven five three Oh nine let's just take that.
Who knows what happened to them.
Right?
But to always go to the singer,
the singer Dow has to successful clothing,
life for children.
That's what they'd comics have never prepared for.
They fit.
You really think you're fucking act is going to work in 20 years.
Do you really do 20 years from today?
Want to go out there and talking about DMT?
I mean I do.
I stopped talking about GMC after the first.
I'm just six months in the Q and A's.
You have to be prepared.
You have to,
you have to evolve this.
Yeah,
well you have to still be relevant because you have to still be doing what you
want to be doing,
you know?
And that's what's really important.
So you are in 20 years from now,
you're still in love with stand up.
I don't suspect that won't be man.
Stand up.
I love stand up as much now as I did when I first started.
If you go to Gallagher Gallagher driven thought about doing a podcast,
you'd say no to because is thinking,
is it like that?
Well,
everybody stand up.
You know is there's,
there's some people that the the not like a podcast sort of a guy on about that.
I'm talking about evolution.
A lot of these guys been a shit to them at the comedy store.
There's rumors about the people get off stage at the comedy store and they'd be
clubbed fucking owners,
right?
They're going,
hey,
wait,
no.
February 13 here's a plane ticket.
See you then it's a different patois.
It was a d.
Even if you see a comic from the 90s and styles a little fucking different guy.
Okay.
You see it and you can't,
you know,
show that you have to evolve.
You know what?
I could still do my comedy.
There's still people that want to see me,
but how we evolve.
I'll do a podcast,
I'll get a webpage,
I'll draw a blog,
I'll do all of these things.
It's very important.
The fucking people that I had.
These guys you go to,
what an idea that is going to enhance it.
They're going to go,
Nah,
I just,
I'll just get my people on the road find that everybody's on Twitter.
We had the discussion before the thing.
One day I find out I'm going to Miami and problem.
I put it on there.
I call fucking the lady's like,
I don't know what I got for radio.
I called Bert Kreischer Birch set to go on Ron and Paul.
I just put on Twitter.
So you're talking about to promote the show to promote the shit.
I'm talking about these shows.
I'm talking about any shit,
right,
right.
I put on Twitter,
Hey,
I'd be suggestions or radio stations in Florida.
I like to go on put the three days I had 20 people contacting me.
So if you're a convenient,
you're not fucking around with Twitter,
you crazy or any businessmen,
anything.
If you're trying to market a product that you have and you're not on Twitter or
on a computer and 20 with people and communicating and putting your videos up
and giving away stuff,
then you're in a different fucking planet.
Take 2012 if you're a community or you can be the funniest guy in the world.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
Part of entertainment today,
I pay for 500 fucking channels a month and soda you six 20 when you had fuel and
all those copies is fucking channels up there and pay for 600 channels a month.
But I'm still on my computer,
50 to 60% of my fucking day.
70% of my day.
I watch a few shows,
the walking dead,
the killing,
but let's fucking face it.
You might catch a documentary.
We take up the only guy,
I don't even like the computer.
There's people live on fucking there.
So if you're not working on there today,
I'm not talking about five years ago,
Ted Tech and I learned that from La and I tell you all the time from Irvine last
summer,
no radio,
he's still sold the place out.
1600 seats and seats,
three pointing times,
five shows.
Yeah,
we stopped.
Do we do still do our friends when we do local radio shows,
you know,
if it's like,
it's the guys that,
uh,
you know,
I've done the show before and I look forward to doing it like,
uh,
like Dale Dudley in Austin,
but we don't have to do anything anymore.
That's,
that's the crazy thing is it's all our fans now.
It's all,
I don't even like that word.
It's all our people now,
you know,
and it's,
uh,
we,
we don't know.
Everyone knows exactly what the fuck is up when they get there.
It's completely different crowd.
Last year on Christmas,
how much did sales go up on a lot?
38% in two years.
You're not going to leave the house to buy.
There's no reason.
Yeah,
that's the Amazon.
I want to suck Mr Amazon's Vic because he's genius.
Listen Bro.
And you can do it on your phone,
but I just got the dolce book to based fucking late.
I got it all.
Whatever.
I want a coconut water.
I want to fuck a week.
Oh,
you can order everything off a fucking that I Amazon,
by the way on Amazon,
you can get on a fucking,
uh,
a book reader APP and you could watch it and read it on your phone.
You could,
you could get by a lot of different guys books as a download and read on a book
reader on your phone so you'd have it on you all the time.
I mean,
the amount of storage that you're your phone has is incredible.
You know,
the little,
uh,
I have the little Amazon App on my iPhone.
I fucking,
I don't know,
20,
30 bucks Amazon App
before you use apples.
I books.
No,
I use that too,
but I use both of them.
They're,
they're both great.
The I books is awesome too.
I books I like,
I really love for the IPAD.
It's the Shit I love.
The turning of the pages as has the graphic.
Have you looked at a new one yet?
No,
I haven't seen it.
It's really hard to tell,
but yeah,
you can kind of see a little bit more depth,
but it's not a huge difference.
Yeah.
To me what it is,
is the iPad something to like when you're sitting on the couch and you're
fucking bored,
you know,
you just fuck around and see what's going on in your email.
See what's going on.
The message board,
I don't,
it's,
it's a temporary thing.
It's like I got to leave in 20 minutes,
let me pick up my iPad for games.
I think it's way better than anything.
Oh yeah.
For moving and Shit.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
The gyroscope in it for kids and I write on right on it.
Yeah,
you could.
You could write in a note pad.
You know what a box when I
go out alone,
that's what I put all my,
yeah,
I do.
She got hooked me up with a light lipid.
Brian,
I,
yeah,
sure.
I'll give you one.
I don't want you to give me one a way to take me to apple and told me what to
buy.
What I say my iPad too.
But whatever you teach me,
I got to take something like $400.
What the fuck are you eating over there?
What are you fucking Mitch American Ale.
I tried to hide these things from you.
They stop.
You know what I'm saying?
I know,
but just talk.
I'm over here thinking,
well,
I took my fish capsules today.
I did.
You got the ultra man.
You got everything here.
I ain't.
You got everything over here.
I
was going to be on opie and Anthony last night.
I was like,
all right,
on the line.
But then I got too tired.
I just hung up by me and Anthony were both up for that Shorty Award Bullshit,
uh,
for web show.
That was nonsense.
Let me tell the story of Joe and so me and like Jim Norton was also up,
I think for me what a shorty shorty award.
This is something I found out during all this shorter your word is it's like you
get nominated by people and then you,
uh,
the most,
the top five or there's all these categories like your,
your best comedian,
best web show and there's a lot of categories.
And so if people start voting for you,
then you know,
you the top seven people I think,
uh,
get,
nominated for that category.
So like out of like hundreds and hundreds of hundreds of people.
I was in the top seven,
I was number three,
I think.
Uh,
and so it was Anthony from opie and Anthony and some wrestler named Zack rider
or something like that.
And uh,
so the,
the,
the top seven or up for this nominee.
And then everyone's started telling me like,
uh,
hey,
you know,
that shit's just a scam.
What they do is they get you everyone to vote for you on Twitter.
And then,
uh,
so all these people are trying to win.
Like Anthony's tweeting,
I'm tweeting,
hey,
please vote for me.
All these people are tweeting.
So it just thinks everyone,
it just advertises the shorty awards.
And then,
so everybody then Ha uh,
who wins the shorty awards they have like,
it's very suspect like who wins.
So it's almost like the shorty words like this is big scam to promote certain
things is do you feel that it's a scam because you lost no,
no,
I heard this before.
It ended and so who won?
I stopped,
I stopped kind of promoting the shorty awards.
I near the end because people were telling me at all about it.
And so then,
uh,
when I watched it like Jim Norton wasn't,
we was up for best comedian.
I don't know who won that.
Anthony was I who I thought we should have one but then this is like
miscellaneous girl that I,
everyone's telling me it's like it's the worst show ever.
And there's like,
she had like one eighth of the vote that Anthony had or one 10th of the above
even.
I tried to generalize about things too much,
but in general,
all the categories we were like,
I think award shows are fucking stupid.
Why would you can,
that's what I feel is,
the only reason why I even questioned it more is because after get nominated,
they have the ceremony in New York and then they immediately sent me an email
for like for the $400 package,
you get to come in and,
and meet with other people and stuff like that.
And as soon as I,
so they're selling you a vacation package or they're selling you like really
expensive tickets,
even if you're nominated for awards.
So you can't go to the award unless you pay to go to the or something like that.
So wait a minute.
So they're offering you to buy tickets to go to an award show or you're
nominated?
Yes,
that is.
So it's a big money making venture moneymaking convention.
And I would say I'm not,
this is just my opinion.
I would say that the people that one,
that there's a reason why they all want it.
You know,
there's a reason why they all want to think it's all horse shit.
I think it's a horse.
I Dunno.
A hug.
And the other weird though because once in a while they give it to somebody
legit like Conan O'brien or something like that just so they could have a photo
of him holding it and then it's like it's don't money may have to like quantify,
like calculate,
look,
we're visible children's shit that's going on right now and that guy said he was
going to keep,
but 90% of the donation or something like that.
That's done.
Amazing.
Yeah,
it's a funny,
people are trying to find ways to make money.
They got him on video.
One of the guys on video words,
I caught that shit before the naked incident.
I will give,
I will give you money directly if you need it,
but,
and it breaks my heart when you see a hurricane or you see an earthquake and you
want us 50 bucks or a hundred but at the back of my mind I say,
why?
Because I've worked for those organizations where you sign up with the cops.
For example,
when you call people and go,
Joe Rogan,
how you doing?
Joe Diaz,
PB 92 here,
we'll call it,
because the cops didn't want to get bulletproof things.
If you sign up with us for advertising in our book,
we will give you a sticker and that goes to the back of your car.
When you get pulled over for a ticket,
you tell the cop you donated and he'll lead.
You see it.
All this bullshit.
So let's say you donate 500 how much do you actually think goes to that?
That's the good question.
30% 30% 30 something percent.
Okay,
so basically your 500 and that's even if it goes,
that's even if it goes at what w we fucking earthquake.
Every catastrophe,
there's always donations and two years later,
what do you read?
Yeah,
somebody clipped the donation.
You Wyclef Jean with the fucking Haiti.
$1 million.
A lot of fucking money.
When people give it to you,
and I'm not saying he's stolen,
I'm not little judge,
but I'm just saying,
you know you have all that money.
Why was he being accused of why Clef is wrong?
His fucking organization for Haiti though,
the Haiti Foundation,
that's just money laundering pretty much,
right?
I don't really,
that's how you,
if you got tons of money.
So I think,
you know what I think,
I think people,
they start out with ideas of doing something that helps,
but they also want to get paid and it's difficult job and they feel like they
should get paid along with helping.
So a certain percentage of the money has to go towards the staff and that's just
how they feel and it becomes a business.
You said to me,
you were going,
nothing wrong with being paid to do charitable work.
I understand.
But if you said to me,
you will go
to Haiti and I gave you a hundred bucks and you said to me,
Joey,
I'm going to take all the money I get and I'm gonna pay for a plane ticket and
whatever.
I then,
as I understand that,
that's what I understand.
I don't understand what I'm giving you a hundred bucks and you got to take Brian
with you and probably for the lights at your office and your car off on it.
Well,
they have to have some sort of infrastructure,
but 30% of what I've given you,
it seems too much,
but I've had 31% of business is fucking really expensive to run,
man.
You know,
it's expensive to buy plane tickets are expensive to ship things.
It's expensive to keep the lights on,
keep the heat on,
keep the air conditioning on,
key people getting checks every fucking week.
Steady checks every week.
You've got to keep money coming in every week in order to just pay these people
to stay inside the organization.
It's a constant money eating machine and I think a lot of people aren't,
are aware of that.
When you think about some,
any,
any charitable organizations like yeah,
everything costs money.
The world costs money.
So it's,
it's,
it's hard for these people to figure out a way to do it and balance it.
Right.
That said,
and you get sound from like the Coney situation you got,
you got some fucking crazy assholes.
That's what you got there.
You know,
you got some guy who could,
that guy who went crazy in San Diego,
could he have put more gay flare and to what he was doing when he was running
around throwing his arms through the air.
And I mean,
that guy clearly has some sort of a weird fucking nutty suppression.
He went nuts.
He pulled off this scam,
made some stupid amount of money.
It probably looked at his paypal account,
did some math,
and just ran outside and said,
I god,
I be me.
And I thought that this was it.
You know,
it was just going to run naked through the streets of San Diego and beat off in
front of fucking passing by a car.
It'd be fair.
He was running with invisible children.
We just couldn't see it.
Oh,
they were all in those.
Yeah.
That's fucking fascinating situation,
man.
That guy made a lot of money really quickly.
Yeah.
If you're gonna have a charity,
you might as well call it something like an invisible children too.
So in the court courtroom,
you could always use a defense.
Like it was called invisible children.
Seriously.
It didn't,
didn't no one figure that out.
I wonder how this is going to play out because it's obvious now that everybody's
been hustled right now.
It's pretty obvious that the guy's crazy.
The other guy said something really tedious.
If you have donated to this guy,
you can get a,
paypal lets you reverse it for up to I think three months.
So it's even longer than if visa card.
So was,
hm.
I wonder who paid and which way.
I think most people probably use paypal.
I want to use it,
but ladies and gentlemen,
I don't want to advise you what to do,
but I think you know Jesus fucking Christ.
Don't let that go.
Cody situation is very unique and stuff.
I'll tell you what's going to scare the shit out.
I'll go Joey guys is the Trevor fucking situation in Florida.
That's not good.
That's good.
That's the beginning of his wheels.
Go to this country right now.
There's wheels going and you could tell me that the kids smoke pot and he got
suspended from school.
Yeah.
That doesn't mean show said that you stopped following the fucking kid.
You know what they're going to have to this guy at somebody.
It's going to get you down in Florida.
Dog with those brothers are fucking crazy and that heat and all that.
My God bought juice and shit.
You know it's going to be bad.
That happened.
Rallies all over the country thing is so scary.
It's very scary.
Gentlemen.
Strap a fucking pair out.
If they don't arrest this mother fucker within the next week and do something,
they got to do something and you know what?
That guy had tried to be a cop.
You injected those shit.
This is an easy story to figure out.
Not only that he was,
he had a string of ridiculous nine one one call Stab my God.
Fucking long.
Nine one one slash two year old kid.
There was a nine year old kid in his neighborhood and he called nine one one
fucking prepared for that one because of that shit though.
Strap on.
I'd give it another 10 days before this.
Something starts.
Something where to start.
We're go in there man.
It has to.
It's going to be like puff fucking fight the power and do the right thing at the
end with the fucking brothers.
We crazy bedstuy and it's going to be fucking,
you know what?
I can't blame them.
What part of Florida is this all going down in Sanford,
Stanford safe,
something like that.
Close to Miami,
I think.
I don't know exactly the point.
We're going to Hollywood.
I'm going to be with Jeff Duncan Trussell at the Improv April 13th,
14th and 15th.
The improv in Fort Lauderdale.
I just been watching this thing or not.
I'm watching this thing escalate just exactly where it is.
See exactly where it is.
A little brother.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting.
You know,
we'll look,
uh,
it's,
it's fucked up man.
There's,
there's no bringing a kid back.
You know,
it's,
it's fucked up period.
We,
even if the kid did something like even if the kid was a punk,
even if the kid was,
I mean,
there is no,
bringing a kid back then were really the most disturbing thing to me always is
lost potential.
You know?
And any,
any person who's been a punk at 15 and 16,
you know,
deserves a chance to learn from their mistakes.
Every kid does.
I mean,
outside of horrible,
sociopathic crimes and murders and things along those lines,
every kid,
you know,
everybody makes mistakes,
especially people without poor guidance or in a bad environment.
So,
you know,
regardless of what happened that day,
I feel terrible because this,
you know,
this,
uh,
a potential is gone.
You know,
that's how he got to look at a kid.
A kid is his potential.
I know so many people look at you.
I know so many people that at one point in their life were not good people.
There were,
there were fucked up to run a bad place,
but they turned around and became some of my favorite people.
You know,
you're a perfect example.
I mean,
you always telling these stories about about kidnapping.
Dude,
fucking tie him up with a machine gun,
but do one of my favorite people.
But you're one of my favorite people on the planet,
you know,
and I,
you come over and play with my kids.
Yeah.
You
know what I'm saying?
It's like people don't realize that people actually absolutely can change.
It is very possible.
So when you see a young kid dying,
even if the kid was doing something bad,
I mean,
you know,
kid was,
yeah,
there's just a huge head
criminals and there's confusion.
People,
kids don't know what the fuck they want to do.
I was lost.
I thought I wanted to do.
And once I did it,
I seen the reality of it.
I never did it again.
And for some people they'll take the lesson,
they run with it,
and for some other people they fucking keep doing what they were doing because
they don't really want to go anywhere.
And I'm really want to go anywhere.
Even in my darkest moments,
I always just wanted a little bit of light so I could shut just to go forward.
That's all.
I was almost like a hallmark card.
That's beautiful.
I wasn't looking for anything.
I was looking for 15 hours just to get me started.
That's it.
To get an apartment,
to get a car.
All I wanted,
but it was between the addiction and the things around me and myself and my
weaknesses.
It was a spinning ball that you can't get yourself out of the weapon.
The fuck does up there watching me that I got a break and whatever and today I'm
not fucking let them know or whatever,
but I'm alive.
When I wake up in the mornings I'm alive though.
I didn't think I was going to be alive at 49 you know the funny you kit.
I didn't want to be alive at 49 but now I want to be alive.
Man.
It's beautiful because I crossed over.
I don't have that thing in the back of your mind,
which is addiction and the same thing people have with their gay or when they're
in the closet.
About something.
They did that in ways that bears heavy on your fucking soul.
It doesn't bear on your psyche,
in your soul.
I always felt less than what I was,
even if I killed,
because I'm still a fucking junkie.
That always circling your fucking don't man.
You know?
And that's why I always,
I feel bad for us.
I see something sometimes and I know exactly what it is.
You know when a guy wants to be a cop,
you guys,
you grew up with that we'll fucking cops.
When they were eight,
they were school guards and they took it a little bit too cool.
I'm like,
bitch,
you don't even get paid for it.
Somebody steal your fucking lunchbox and they in the head with it,
there's a lot of kids and they grow up and they,
you know,
they have the flag on their shirt.
She's just Christ.
You know,
these specs are taking over and then they go for the cop test and there's a
problem.
They fucking psychologically fucking deranged.
So now they become a security guard at a mall and they take that job to fucking
seriously last night I'm mythos.
What Kevin James Movie,
Paul Blart Mall Cop to get dark and for some people it's a job for some people.
I got a nine one one here.
Shut the fuck up.
I stole a pack of fucking God.
You fucking moron.
Some people like to control people.
You know when I watch a cop show and they high five when they busted him,
but oh,
we did.
What'd you do?
Did you know that?
Uh,
Tim Sylvia is a cop.
No.
Yeah.
Where I forgot.
I think it's somewhere.
I mean it was cold out wherever it was.
I guess probably Iowa.
Southern Iowa.
Yeah.
It might not be Iowa.
No,
he was a fucking cop.
He was a,
is doing a lot of,
um,
a lot of us ships as a,
as a police officer.
They showed,
they went on tour with them or tour on tour with them on to went on,
uh,
on,
when he was out doing his rounds.
And uh,
will they say cruising?
What'd you say?
Cops follows cruiser following his cruiser.
Following a following around.
Isn't it funny that it can be a cruiser with a cop,
but anybody else,
you look in the soccer guys deck,
it's trolling now you're cruising,
you know if you're cruising cruising for men.
Right.
Anyway,
he's um,
he's,
he,
he does,
he's trying to get back into the UFC I guess,
but he's um,
doing like,
you know,
like,
oh,
he's taking some small fights and he's works as a cop.
I was actually likes doing it,
you know,
it seems like it'd be a nice guy to get pulled over by a big chip on the
shoulder.
Yes.
Some guys,
you could tell some people want to be cops with the right reason,
for the right reasons,
but I mean that's,
those are logic.
There's a way to get fucking flies with Gaba instead of fucking vinegar.
Last class that I get alcohol,
they do Monday night to do the comedy contest,
come back with the laugh factory.
I pull over by the Ha and the kid says,
dog,
you want to go up?
I said,
sure,
I'll close the show out.
While they do they count that they write.
It was black heavy audience last night.
Okay.
If there was 60 people,
there was a 30 brothers,
they went to the sea as well.
Black kid from Chicago.
I didn't watch him.
I got there late and I went on stage,
whatever again,
off the show ended were outside.
I'm talking to the AG casino and his brothers standing,
three of Nice guys just talking,
talking about tomorrow's job,
but there's no cars on Lankershim so that there's no cars parked.
So the one guy,
is it the street,
six inches from the sidewalk talking.
You know how sometimes you're smoking a cigarette away from people?
Fucking carp is a likership.
Well,
I'm watching this cop.
He said the light and all of a sudden he comes up to where these guys are
standing.
It stops and 10 cars or behind the traffic and he just stops and looks at him.
He puts this thing on.
He goes,
Hey,
get back on the fucking sidewalk.
If the guys like all of a sudden I'm doing a shoe shine,
the light like this tool that your people out there walking around,
this guy's being fucking Johnny bananas out there.
So then he puts the light on me.
I'm just over there by the corner talking to the ex didn't go what?
And he goes,
he turns around and makes sure you turn.
He goes,
what'd you say to me?
I said,
God,
you over there harassing three fucking black guys with the problems we've got
this country going on right now.
Use Your fucking head.
What's wrong?
Where you,
and he looked at me.
What's your name?
I got my got my id in the car.
I wasn't drinking.
I got another bad guy,
but we'd look,
I don't give a fuck.
That's what you're worried about.
Three guys.
What do you care?
Look at it.
Well,
you can't let them get hit by the fucking car doing his job.
No,
but your fucking business,
there's things you look at and there's things you don't fucking look at.
What did you ever go to Hollywood?
You drive into crossing the street as I fucking all set.
There's a fucking new organs.
There's a bunch of traffic and Hollywood and you go around and you realize it's
a cop pulling over a homeless guy.
That's another,
the quarter lane there puking.
So he pulls over like Adam 12 so you can have all this fucking traffic.
Really Bitch.
Where were you when they were shooting motherfuckers up in north Hollywood
motherfucker.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they act like really you're going to pull over to bother a whole bi thing.
We can agree that there are some county cops.
No,
but there's cops.
Great cops to know.
There's great
fucking cops.
The ones that look to you for what the fuck it is.
Yeah.
And they're like dog,
are you fucking serious?
Yeah.
We've talked about this before on the podcast and one of the problems is quotas.
You know they,
they to an order to show that they're doing their job,
they have to catch people doing shit,
especially speeding and certain times of the month you guys get crazy speed.
It's ridiculous.
It's incredible that that's a,
that's like,
it's really a tactic because then what would happen if it was ever completely
resolved?
What,
what,
what the fuck would they ever do if everybody just follow the speed limit.
Cause that's common man.
This Google car shit,
when they were going to have cars that are going to be there.
You're going to get in them and you could fucking be on your computer.
You could be doing whatever you want.
It's a personal craft that's going to be able to follow a pattern and get you
somewhere.
You're not going to have to do any driving anymore.
This is,
it's 100% on the way.
If you've seen the Google videos,
right,
Brian?
Crossing guards,
cars,
Google cars,
you have it.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
I would say prepare to get your fucking mind blown.
Google hold ups.
Pull up on that thing.
Google car drives itself,
Dude.
Google is for sure skynet.
There's no doubt about it.
Google.
Google is,
it's going to be one day when when we talk back like the way we view the ancient
Egyptians and we tried to decipher their,
their society.
Google's gonna play a huge part in the myth of the,
the,
the downing of the American society and the downing of the Western world.
Is that commercial first?
Mm.
Looks like
the car.
What did you,
what did you pull up?
A Google car
car that drives itself.
Scoot back a little.
Sorry.
A very cautious driver.
They're like most people,
much of my life depends on the motor car.
Oh,
she's telling me fast forward this over.
kind of fuel.
It uses the changing something far more fundamental.
When I say,
how can I say I would love,
she seems like a nice lady.
I'm just saying that she does have or just join a four foot.
She does not pull forward so we could watch this fucking everyone.
There's a couple of Google commercials.
So let's just say Google car drives itself.
Did you Google that?
I thing driving the Google card.
It sounds okay.
But they did one of them.
The one I wanted to show you the leap from search engines to car engines,
but not for just any car.
The new Google car is unlike anything else in the road because it drives itself.
Yes.
Becky worldly joins us via Skype and you went along for a test drive.
Thank you very [inaudible].
I did.
Good Morning Robin.
Yeah,
you,
you heard that right?
Google the Internet company has been secretly working on a sophisticated
combination of hardware and software that could revolutionize the feasibility of
a self driving car.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you are all about to witness while the first time on any screen really want
things to come and your car up tomorrow.
Ah,
old visions of futuristic cars.
First cruise control,
then cars that park themselves and ones that helped you avoid fender benders,
but now
and now it's driving cars,
self driving car and from of all companies Google.
It uses cameras inside to a spot,
traffic lights and other things and also uses this thing on the top,
which is a scanning laser.
They say this car is already driven itself,
140,000 miles.
She's driven itself.
Really,
here's how it works.
You tell the car,
your destination,
it plots around,
it's aware of speed limits,
traffic patterns and known obstacles.
So the wheel just turned completely by itself,
completely by itself.
It's not intended to replace drivers,
but to help them super cruise control.
Imagine clicking the button for auto drive when you wanted to dial a phone
number or read a text.
She's,
he wished to drive it just fine.
If you wish to waste 52 minutes of commute traffic,
go ahead.
You may guess,
in fact,
Google tout safety is their motivation.
They say this technology could one day cut traffic deaths in half.
Whoa.
He got really nervous.
Yeah.
He must've thought I saw somebody coming in down the on ramp.
So how does it handle stop signs and alternating turns with other cars?
It intersection.
Yeah.
Cross walk ahead.
It would be the same probably with,
with pessary and safety in the sense of using the,
uh,
the,
the radio signals to check and see who's in front of them.
Who's around.
Yep.
But how does it handle the unexpected?
How about a little game of chicken?
Oh my God.
Fuck that.
She's stepping in front of the car,
but I was really scared.
My hope was that'd be transformed society to make a traffic safer,
more efficient,
and also more pleasurable.
Wow.
Well Google says they have no plans of cars to the consumer market anytime soon.
They don't know what it would cost when it does come to market.
But besides say you say this hopes to,
they hope this reduces emissions,
reducing our dependence on fossil fuels and Robyn eases congestion.
Wow.
That's incredible man.
Because um,
you know,
you see the w if folks who are just listening to this,
the video shows this,
this thing on top of it,
like some sort of a star trek thing spinning around in a circle really fast and
it's getting well images of all the cars in the neighborhood and where they're
coming from and it's like an overhead view.
It's really crazy that this did not seem like a good idea.
Are you kidding me?
It seems all right now.
It seems awesome,
Dude.
It seems awesome.
Would you trust that though?
Well,
I like driving.
I like the feeling.
I have some cool cars.
I like the feeling of like a sporty car that handles well.
And,
and I mean even like I said,
even not even driving irresponsibly,
just driving at normal highway speeds,
a sporty cars.
Like it's fun.
It feels like you're kind of doing a real,
you know,
it's a ride.
But that would take all that out of it.
Then it would just be,
you would just want to be comfortable,
but if you'd be a lot safer,
what happens if you like fucking right.
I may push on that button and let it do its thing while I do a text message.
As an example.
You're on freeway,
you look down,
you're texting it.
The computer that it's running on for some reason just starts spinning.
You know like the beach ball,
like thinking about something like as a little free little hiccup and then a
semi slams on its brakes and you're not looking up and you go right into the
back of the seminar.
That couldn't be possible.
You can't trust it that mine is a computer.
This car wasn't ready to come out tomorrow.
You'll be fucked with vantage.
I see this car because you eat a cookie.
You're driving those numbers up,
hits you.
You're like,
fuck this up.
Take me home.
Take me home bitch.
And you just,
that's the only advantage of something like this.
Well,
the advantage would be that this thing has gone over a hundred thousand miles
with no accidents.
That's a credible,
and it's on regular roads.
The,
it may be that that's a way better way for us to get along.
I think it probably is.
I mean,
would you be safe,
you know,
doing that if the,
if the whole thing was wired that way and that's the only people got around,
I think you'd probably be safer.
The only problem we would have as if what day the system cracked and we had a
lot of those cars gold around it,
all the cars which started going fucking crazy and started doing 90 or what
seems inevitable though,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
no,
no.
This is,
I'm pretty sure these motherfuckers got,
they don't have the car that flies right over you.
I traffic,
we'll bill you just pop that motherfucker and it goes up 10 feet in the air as
long they're going to have that rechecked.
Well,
do you know that was a event originally rather that's what they thought the
helicopter was going to be.
They thought the helicopter was going to be able to replace the car and everyone
would just fly around in helicopters.
That was the initial idea.
I can't imagine how horrible that would be.
Everyone had fucking two helicopters flying all night long flying over your
house.
There are no one would have any privacy,
you know,
like even it didn't matter.
It doesn't matter where you live.
You could live behind the tallest of gates in the highest of mountains,
so and just fly up there and just fly over your fucking house.
Bid Sai over your house.
You can never control,
you know,
they could fuck with you.
So he didn't like your houses and stuff.
Yeah,
they could.
They could just throw rocks off the top of their helicopter at you.
He on those houses opened the window and just drop some shit on your house.
They could always be over your house.
You could never stop.
You know,
you could stop someone from driving in your driveway.
How the fuck do you stopped them from flying over your house?
Like climb down a ladder and has sex on people's houses would be like popular to
do like celebrities houses.
People would be mad as fuck cause it hear that helicopter and they don't even
bother.
Like having a guy take off and come back.
No,
they keep it hovering.
I'm going to
fucking beat an apocalypse now.
Live in that fucked the movie.
That would be a nightmare.
Then they'd be have to be more helicopters in the sky that are cops to stop.
These motherfuckers pull over,
pull over.
You know,
how would you then make them pull over?
Yeah,
you get too close.
You guys are going to hit blades and everybody dies.
What if we all have it?
Hot Air Balloons?
That'd be pretty crappy.
That'd be cool.
That it's sky would look,
oh I said,
well we all had hot air balloon.
Well be falling out of the fucking sky.
All the ideas everywhere.
I'll tell husbands and wives should get rid of each other.
Taking each other up in a hot air balloon and fucking shoot a hole in the
parachute.
We both go,
you mother fucker,
boom,
boom.
But we could dress up or hot air balloons with certain designs and like,
like Joey D's or just have a huge like and will not be by there are design
monkey or something just sitting in this balloon floating around afterwards
Dawg.
That shit in Colorado.
In Colorado they have the big festivals.
I think also in Arizona and Colorado.
I would wake up early.
It's Snowmass village to go see what they would do with it.
Then with the whole fucking thing.
We went down there but it was the Jane.
We were supposed to go there.
It was canceled because the weather.
Yeah.
We made a trip down to Colorado Springs and God,
the fucking traffic backwards.
Brutal.
That's bad.
This one lane this way,
one lane.
How many people are here?
There's a lot of people here.
Why don't you expand this shit?
You crazy fuck cause of it.
Well,
some of the shit they just save for the whole Patois.
Yeah.
Fucking why with natural.
Well,
there's some,
there's some roads that are preposterous.
Still the amount of people that are traveling through them.
For them to be that narrow,
the worst road they have up there.
Is it dependence past?
That's the worst thing I've ever been on in my life.
That's what connects Aspen to Denver.
But it closes.
Right?
People are asking me like in real life,
like,
like they don't get it.
Like people,
somebody just asked me,
is it really?
Do you know if there's an olive garden in Vegas?
Like a friend of mine?
And I'm like,
come on dude.
That's,
are you being serious?
Like you think that's funny?
Like why would I know that?
What does that have to do with what you just asked me?
Why I was laughing?
Oh,
so you were just reading,
somebody just texted me.
Wait,
dependence.
Plants closes the late August and it opens June because that's how dangerous it
is.
Cause that's where it starts slow at first.
Like it slows everyone else a month later because that's the higher elevations.
And the good thing about it is when you,
uh,
hit aspect as you go through the stick,
it's told it's two lanes but to skinny fucking leads like as skinny as they
could be.
I allowed by law and this some turns that you a dog that just,
but at the end of that they have the,
the whatever black uh,
black wolf and at the end of it's like a bed and breakfast and the lady's got
wolves and they fucking how at night like it.
Yeah.
So it's pretty cool for you everyday.
The crazy thing is if you're on those roads and someone breaks down,
thoughts on,
it's crazy cause you got to kind of help them cause there's nobody anywhere,
anywhere near that and it's probably no cell phone service either.
There's,
that's UC to a broken down there.
You got to take a real big chance that you might have to take somebody in your
car and bring them with you.
I don't like doing that man.
That's a good scam up there.
Fuck that.
Yeah,
it is a good scam.
People pull guns out,
pull your car over.
Especially have a nice car.
The pretend to have a flat tire.
And especially if it's like a guy and a girl and then,
you know,
they look like respectable people.
Super,
super normal scam,
you know,
hijack people's cars.
They just found some girl in Vermont.
They,
uh,
found her body in the woods and her,
her car was running and her kid was in the car.
It's really fucked up shit,
man.
When you hear those kinds of stories and you're like,
man,
he really do have to worry about people,
man.
You really do have to worry about people out there because every now and then
someone's in the wrong place at the wrong time in 99% of the people that you run
into are really nice
people.
And then not trying to hurt anybody.
But there's a,
there's been,
there was another instance in,
I think it was New Hampshire,
this was in Vermont.
I think there was an instance in New Hampshire where the same thing a woman,
uh,
turned up missing and her kid was in the car,
unharmed.
And,
uh,
then it turned out she was dead and they don't have a,
they never found a suspect.
They didn't know who the fuck did it.
This is people out there that have gotten away with murder.
They're still out there.
That's,
that's a fact.
100% this ain't CSI.
They're too fucked up situations where,
I remember one time I was like 14,
it's still like to fetus,
Node Jersey and the buses weren't working.
I wanted to shoot hoops.
So I walked the Saint Michael's,
but we ended up staying there till like midnight and I had no buses.
They had to walk home in the fucking car,
pulled over and he's like,
get in the car.
You want to ride?
Yeah.
He goes,
where do you go?
And I used to get off,
I'd see yours.
And I remember that he started playing with the ball.
The ball was between my legs and he started playing with the ball.
If you want,
we come to my house.
I got games over there and shit and I didn't know what to do.
I didn't have the budget.
I've got to tell you,
I was a knock them out and there was a god because at my life,
the door opened.
I hadn't closed it all the way or something of that door open.
I just said thank you.
And I ran the fuck out of there and he made it.
You turn it.
But you know,
I went through,
I could,
I cut loose shirts and parking and all that shit and he couldn't find me.
Scary Shit right there.
You imagine being one of those motherfuckers too.
And that's your compulsion.
You're the compulsion is to go after kids.
Wow.
Terrible must like when that Sen Dusky Guy,
do you know that story that he got taped?
They got him on a wire tap from earlier.
Before all this broke out from years back.
There was a woman and he,
uh,
was accused of doing something inappropriate with her son,
and she was talking to him on the phone and he said,
I wish I was dead.
That's what he said when they were talking to him about it.
He said,
I wish I was dead.
That's how they feel.
What a terrible sick,
fucking broken thing in the brain to make you do that big.
That's what that thing that people have,
but isn't it fucked up that the brain is so weird like that,
that it can do something like that.
Maybe someone can find themselves somehow or another and that kind of a terrible
jail of a life.
But here's the beauty of it.
If you really read this whole thing of the showers,
this fucking guy was pleading to get caught.
Really look at it.
Listen,
if I have a little boy,
you think I'm going to shower him at the school for Jim.
You're fucked.
You think about it.
Take them to a school gym.
I don't think they have any place else to go.
You know,
just working.
You also had a white thing.
One of the kids said that he was over the house and he was screaming for help
and the wife ignored him.
He was screaming for help when he talked about it,
like help.
This guy's fucking me.
Like the first time Sandusky fucked him.
He's screaming for help and the wife just ignored him have.
It's probably any other room mastery.
Your wife,
uh,
they,
they also lived,
apparently he lives like right across the street from a school yard.
So he sits in the back porch and he watches kids play from his fucking house.
Like,
Whoa,
this is amazing.
That guy was in that position for so long.
Maybe if you think the world makes sense and that things,
things come to light always.
I not necessarily,
man,
they kept that a secret for a long goddamn time.
He,
maybe the people deep inside knew about it,
but we didn't know about it for a long goddamn time.
That's a pretty impressive bit of secret keeping,
you know,
I wonder how many other secrets or like that out there,
especially in places where it becomes sort of cult like,
like Penn state.
I mean,
when that guy,
when nobody even wanted to hear why they fired Joe Paterno,
they just want to turn cars over and light things on fire.
Like you can't,
you can't fire him,
you can't fire him.
There was riots,
man.
People were just going crazy and demonstrating and screaming and yelling and you
know,
they were really mad.
They were really mad.
They just,
they would never even think that he could have been somehow or another aware
that is the guy who was working with for years was like kid fucker.
But he might have been,
he might have been,
they might've let it slide.
That's some scary shit.
That guy took kids with him on vacation.
That guy took kids with him to games and they stayed in the same room.
This is a dark,
dark,
dark shit.
You know,
people should have known about that a long time ago.
But you know what's crazy?
Charles was one of those kids.
I went to the camps,
I was a pal.
Basketball.
The cops slept in the room with you and you know what man?
I sit and let pick them all that Shit and how lucky I am.
Nobody ever blow for a week.
I didn't like that shit.
But it's just a kid like I never really,
I don't know what that world would be like if it's so fucking dark for a child.
Any crime against a child,
it's so dark because it stays with them forever,
changes their life,
changes their life.
It makes him adjust to life with that.
It's just sits with your soul so much of those years,
those formative years.
Uh,
and the really scary things that supposedly,
I mean the,
they're thinking is the people that perpetrated or ones who were victims
themselves and that's the,
it fucking short circuits their whole thing and makes them want to molest
children.
That's terrible man.
It's the whole thing is they almost want to bring someone into it.
Like it's like,
like a vampire,
you know,
like someone infecting someone else with the same thing that they got,
and that's how you pass it on.
I mean,
I wonder how many references and how much of the mythology of the vampire is
based on things like that,
you know,
that could easily what it would be from,
someone who has something horrible done to them when they're younger,
they become that horrible thing.
You know,
there's probably one person that started at all,
you know,
because he was the first person on my list,
a kid,
and then it just grew and grew a monkey's man.
The thing is,
if you look at monkeys,
and I say monkeys,
by the way,
I know that it's apes,
it's chimpanzees.
I know it's apes.
Monkey.
Sounds cool.
So I use monkey.
You're not supposed to do that.
But if you look at like,
if you look at Bonobo,
chimpanzees,
they are the closest to us as far as genetically them and regular chimpanzees
are closest to the other primates.
But nobos fucked the shit out of each other.
Everybody fucks everybody.
The only people that don't fuck is the mother doesn't fuck the sun.
And I think that's it.
I think the men fucked their daughters.
The,
uh,
the females,
you know,
like they'll fuck sisters to fuck everybody.
Everybody gets fun.
It's weird because you'd think like,
it'd be interesting to see like,
yeah,
that that monkey has molested this monkey and this monkey has molested and I get
the one that got molested first poop more.
The other one,
you know,
he's got a real job.
There's no,
there's no one gets out alive in the jungle.
Everybody's getting fucked,
right?
This isn't,
it's not like,
it's,
it's not like this,
you know what it is is just a rampant fuck festival.
The Banabos,
they settle all their arguments with fucking,
it's crazy gay sex,
straight sex.
It's nuts.
Everybody fucks everybody.
There's no monogamy at all.
You know,
and the were really nutty thing is there's a giant leap between that and
monogamous relationships that most people try to keep together in the,
in the human world.
Like that's,
uh,
and as far as behaviorally,
it's really kind of the antithesis of what the Banabos,
our closest ancestors do and how they get by,
you know,
they just fuck everybody and we just try to keep it together and only fuck one
person.
It's kind of fascinating when you think about it,
but those,
uh,
those crazy monkeys,
they fuck everything man.
But nobo squad.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's almost,
we're trying to get past all that because we realized that it's a selfishness in
that you shouldn't only,
she'll only be able to have sex with in our rationalizations.
Someone who understands what sex is and someone who is an adult can make their
own decisions.
That's like,
that's how a normal cultural handles it.
Even though the,
they want it when they're younger and people become sexual when they're younger.
We've decided that,
you know,
if in order to keep society together,
you can't just go around as a 40 year old person banging 13 year olds.
So it's just crazy.
It doesn't matter if they have a period that's just shits repo posterous you
know,
you didn't even giving them a chance.
It's like it's cheating.
It's shooting fish in a barrel.
It's,
you know,
it's molestation.
It's not,
it doesn't matter if they like it.
You know,
we,
we made some rational,
smart decisions when it comes to that shit.
No,
my kids are how old kids are,
you know,
I can't toe sometimes he can't suppress symptoms of cocaine.
1616 and 17 year olds.
There's a lot of them that look like women.
Man Prays level about the Sabbath light before a couple it upbeat.
You don't have to school over here and kids are question.
There was a girl with shorts,
you know you're in your car.
That's really hard when you look over.
She was crossing the street.
I'm thinking of myself,
I could do something like that.
Of course you didn't even look at it.
I can't even look at this girl.
Of course you couldn't because you're a moral person and because,
but to look at him,
Jesus Christ,
how could somebody fake?
How old were these girls?
What are you looking at?
They had to be fucking high school.
Okay.
That's where it gets tricky dog.
When it's like 1617 and they started looking like women in their five foot nine
it gets,
it's almost impossible but even gets tricky even with the trick I guy like you,
you're a moron and I look at them,
it would go of course would be a conquest from me.
Of course being a bearish for a guy like me that right,
but that's in the context of our culture and the context of your body.
Your body would want to fuck that girl,
Joe d as if you were alone with her and you and her were on an island and she's
cuddling up with you every night to sleep and then she just reaches down.
He packaged,
rubs your balls and starts kissing your ear and your Dick is hard.
Like a Goddamn Crowbar.
Yeah.
She might only be 17 but her pussy is dripping down her leg.
You touch her thigh,
you feel it dripping.
You remember that when they were 17 and we're going to chant.
They would get so wet.
They would gush.
Remember that shit?
Yeah,
you'd fuck her.
Okay.
I don't judge oily and I was about 20th 19 I worked at an electrical supply,
a supply house with electric.
We all took those warehouse jobs,
but the guy that had the warehouse had to be 48 and his girlfriend,
his wife,
I just turned 17 and he had been with her since she was 13 Oh,
I don't,
that was legal at the time.
I guess it was legal.
He had the gun.
You have been in trouble,
but he got a pregnant so they had to stay together.
But he was a group man dating a girl in high school.
She wasn't all there and he wasn't all there,
you know.
I mean obviously you could see it,
but just the thought of him telling me,
yeah,
my wife was 17 or 18 I'm like,
he goes,
we've been together for five years.
Why could you imagine when
picking a girl out?
And I like when she was like 12 and they were just friends with her until she's
18 and then you start putting the moves on her cheese repeat.
I think about dude,
there's some of them that they're there.
The age of consent is really low.
Yeah,
like 16 as Hawaii or something like,
I think that's why I think it's,
well,
I'll have to figure this out.
This is all right.
Here we go.
The lowest,
it seems like 15 is Colorado.
15 Jesus Christ can be still real to be real.
I don't know what year this is.
1999 what does this Jersey goes to bite you then?
He's like,
what was George [inaudible] in 1999 Jersey was it,
by the way,
that's pretty fascinating.
16 and 18 I guess.
1618 it must mean boys,
girls.
Why?
For Boys it's probably 16 girls and say,
damn,
that's fucking crazy.
Or is it girl?
Boy?
No,
I would think boys younger age 16 if the man is 21 or older,
the girl has to be 16 if the female is over 12 what?
12 hold on a second.
I can marry 12 year old,
some of them.
Oh my God.
This is in 1999 Connecticut.
15 Colorado 15 that means you could fuck a 15 year old man.
Just just a few years ago,
Michigan 16 Minnesota 16 wow.
The most of the country by the way,
is not 18 yeah,
this is back in tooth in 1999 I didn't knew that.
The dude from the dude from Los married that whatever 15 yeah,
North Carolina,
16 North Dakota 16 it all goes down to South Carolina.
1414 in south myrtle beach.
wow,
that's incredible.
That's probably what it is.
Girls,
14 years old and you're fucking a 16 year old.
Right?
But what does,
she has like a lot of cheeseburgers and she's like way advanced for her age.
I still,
what are you talk about Joe,
the meat.
You don't talk about anything.
You show them cartoons when you bang a full doggy style,
what does that look?
You don't do that Chili.
I'm just kidding.
I know.
You have to be the stand.
We'll be animalistic,
man.
It's natural to be attracted to a girl that has a great body regardless of if
she's 18 or 19 or you know,
some of them 17 they look like you remember like,
um,
who was the Traci Lords?
Traci Lords.
When she first burst on the scene,
she was like this really famous porn star because it turned out she did all
these films.
She got like real famous,
but she was underage.
She was like 14,
15.
My Hunger Games is still popular.
Everyone has to eat that girl out.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I haven't seen hunger games,
so I don't know.
And it's all about a girl.
They don't say shit about it.
I don't want to,
I don't know anything about it.
I went to see you.
Is it good?
I heard it's really good.
That's why I don't want to hear [inaudible] Doug Vinson.
Hey Doug Benson.
So silly bitch.
So we love him.
Just Silly Bitch Louisville.
Oh Shit.
Duncan Trussell,
Louisville,
Kentucky.
Shit.
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday,
boom.
Sherlock.
A lot.
It boom.
Wednesday tightening down from my,
uh,
my special,
which is April 20th.
And Atlanta at the Tabernacle.
Joe Diaz will be in the house as always.
Every fucking show that I recorded ever since the beginning.
Joe D has been a part of that shit.
That's right.
And that's um,
so that's um,
on four 20 and Atlanta and the first shows are already sold out.
So the second show is about half sold out right now.
So get on that shit.
We're going to have a good time.
It's going to be fun.
And then I'm gonna release it.
Louis C K style five bucks online,
which you're doing by the way too with a documentary you're going up doing,
no,
I had a blue light today.
April 2nd is presales that I've released the Friday the 13th at the last is and
what is it?
It's either you or the priest.
Okay.
The documentary,
I think I'm going to release on Friday the 13th to cause the graphic guy thought
he gives you or the priest is already out.
It's all how pay loads,
but people want to buy it on iTunes.
Oh,
just want to buy an iTunes.
There's people that just got right to the accounts and you are the priests on
iTunes.
And went that went on one on that Friday the 13th,
Friday the 13th.
And then um,
mockumentary the graphic guy just called police.
He says,
take up the other week.
We could release something second as we planned,
but now we'll just wait for the graphics now what is this documentary?
He bald man,
I,
I started making those bad flavors.
Stupid fucking videos,
you know,
and I got great responses and it was funny what people wanted to see.
You mean the,
the,
the MMA ones?
No,
just the ones with me go to the weeks go fuck German.
God taking a shower with the cat,
the cat that likes to get wet and shit and just fucking around.
You know,
when people started emailing me shit that they thought would be interesting and
I'm like,
you can't give people what the fuck they want all the time.
But I really made sense.
They're like,
we want to see what this calm guy looks like was like my friend Carl,
my
bows and over,
does he really exist?
We want to see what lubes looks like.
Right.
Because he really started and I started taking a bat and I want to Twitter and
asked with donations and I got money.
I got a camera,
the camera man and went to Jersey and I take my,
my grammar school,
so my fucked up buddies just to tell some stories.
And then that night we,
you see me,
I did a one man show us around it.
So that would put the pieces together.
That sounds great.
Well,
it's five bucks.
I don't even know if I'm going to charge for it.
It was just something I wanted to do just to let you know what it really is.
I wanted to show people that,
you know,
my parents died.
It seems like a really bad thing when you're a kid.
It really does it.
It's a horrible thing.
But I was,
I was a fucking Spanish kid and this Italian and Irish community with normally
is more racist than fucking retarded.
Do you know what I'm saying?
They love throw a spic or nigger around and wait,
John and all these shit.
I love it.
I got nothing against it.
But these people opened up their hopes to me.
And then part of the reason when I was in that prison,
sitting there going,
you know,
now they want the people who hated me growing up,
that the ones that said I was just a junkie,
they want,
there's a handful of people that fed me and took care of me and gave me clothes
and never talked about it,
getting it bread.
They'd bring me fucking full food in the hotel.
So I just wanted to just go show these people.
That's all I wanted to do.
That's it.
I don't want to release this.
And Sundance,
when you got some great stories,
man,
just mean the actual people's that's guaranteed entertainment.
Eh,
you know,
when it's nothing,
I'm not going to fucking release that Sun dance.
I ain't no fucking whatever.
I just did this for these Twitter people.
We have such a great time on Twitter now and Facebook.
This is my morning from six to fucking nine.
I'm up there playing music.
Call them cock suckers,
enhances us like we sent the home until we don't have fans.
This is a network.
Dunkin and I talked about it on our,
uh,
on his podcast.
You know,
Duncan Trussell family hour.
I did it,
um,
the other day and one of the things that he was talking about how great it is
now that essentially everybody that were hanging around with like everybody is
doing great.
He is doing great on the road,
Dunkin is doing great,
you're doing great,
everything's doing great.
It's like it's,
it's building down the point where we can all,
like,
we all feel really good about everything and everything is,
it's,
it's like we really truly are like pumping each other up.
We really truly are bringing each other,
which is really an artist's colony,
which is what the comedy store started doing.
We just kept taking it listed this week.
I'm in Miami and you were Louisville.
There's nothing more than the world I wanted to do was be in Louisville with
you.
It's,
it's,
we have so much fucking fun,
but it's cool to break it up a little bit.
Every now and then what's going on?
That squad is out there and now you're in Louisville,
Kentucky,
so growers and Fucking Connecticut that's quite represents or not there were
clogging up the middle,
were clogging up the old war in the middle of that fucking octagon.
You know what I'm saying?
We're not against the fence.
No ball in the middle of the fucking I go.
It's because of the podcast and because of the Internet,
you know,
the,
the people had been looking for something that's a little bit more wild than the
shit they've getting fed on radio and the,
they're getting fed on television and this,
there's a lot of people out there that think like us,
they just don't have anybody else there that are,
that's on the internet or that's,
you know,
in any form of media that's expressing things that they're feeling,
and people are worried about their position and they're worried about the
reputation and that worried about,
you know,
not getting crazy or saying too many things or let's not discuss that.
Let's not discuss this.
And when you,
you get to a,
a place where you can do something like this podcast and do it for a long time,
that those people really get to know who the fuck you are and you really can
help each other.
They send you links,
they send you interesting shit.
They send you information,
they send you encouragement,
it pumps you up and me,
come on,
when you,
when you get all those,
uh,
those tweets from people love you on the podcast,
it feels great.
It's a nice pump you up.
You want to say thank you to as many of as possible.
It's like this big ripple.
When I had the surgery,
you know how many fucking people tweeted be paperwork over this cause repair the
repair.
How many people offered me massages and come to Orange County and we'll do this
via and come to Santa Monica.
We'll do this by you.
Fucking kidding me.
Like some people,
you know,
they were like,
dog,
where are you doing PT at?
I'll do it for free.
I don't want nobody to do that for free.
I pay you.
But just that thing that they weren't people.
Ooh.
Oh right.
People hit me up every day.
Like,
how's your day when these fucking fine,
but Jesus Christ,
how Bison you to ask?
Nice of you to ask.
People sent me a workout.
There was a doctor that sent me a workout,
a jeep man.
Uh,
he said that could be weeks Chubb.
He took time out of his fucking schedule from New York Institute of
reconstructive knee surgery.
Okay.
But he listens to this podcast that follows me on Twitter,
whatever.
He sent me four weeks to Ravi exercises I had to do for that week at home.
Just straight that might be,
and I didn't even fucking told me go get a rubber band and tie it and use the
rubber band.
I mean this is a guy that's a doctor and every week I,
my g mail account,
every month I get the workout for the week.
So I was going to PT,
but I was also doing his workout.
Wow.
Because that's what he specializes it.
Cause he said that when you're 20,
when you're 45,
you know,
but this is different.
He goes,
it won't be falling into these exercises.
He wanted to strengthen the essential parts of the,
at that age he told me what vitamins to take.
What,
I mean this guy was great.
This is a part of you that's very nice,
but on the other hand,
how many people email you about comedy and Sam started,
what do I do?
And you fucking cut right to the chase,
right?
I'll just get on stage.
People hit you all the time.
Dog Up doing this.
I got to quit smoking dog cause I'm going to be,
I've got to quit smoking weed because I'm going to be a mailbag and quit smoking
week.
They're offering you a fucking job by you being a knucklehead.
We're all helping each other out of here and the first time in my life and my
career,
I'm having a fucking fun time.
I'm telling you.
They called me for our dishes now and I'm like,
go fuck yourself.
I do better on Twitter.
Suck my Dick.
All I gotta do is put on what I'm looking for.
An active job sub you'll fucking hit me up.
Is half the people on your network,
a fucking writers from shows.
Yeah,
there's a lot of leg.
No,
no.
So this Twitter is becoming something,
you know in the 80s it was cocaine.
Now it's Twitter and Facebook.
You don't need that shit to be part of a social fucking network.
You know what I'm saying?
I definitely think that there's the best time ever to get your shit out there
without having a real ally and how would I show or you don't need anybody
anymore.
And the group of all of us together,
like the loosely based group,
I mean oop named us death squad because I came into the opiate Anthony show
wants with Eddie Bravos,
a Jujitsu black belt and Tait Fletcher was a giant fuck a gorilla and then may
fighter and he's like,
Holy Shit.
Joe Rogan brought in the desk squad and that sort of stuck and we started using
it as a goof.
But having a loosely based group or we're all together just because we love each
other and we're friends and we're all funny and we all worked together and hang
out together and pump each other up.
You become a part of something and as that part of something like I really feel
like when I see that Dunkin is a on the road making great money and then Ari
selling out in this place and killing them in Vancouver and I see all that,
it makes me feel great.
It makes me smile,
you know,
it makes me fired up.
I feel like,
you know as a,
as a group like that,
when you have a whole bunch of people,
the more everybody is doing well and the more everybody's happy and the more
everybody's sort of progressing.
It inspires you to do the same and inspires you to,
to work hard,
inspires you to,
to continue to produce shit.
Get out there and bang,
you're fucking sets out new shit.
You know?
I'm always busy.
I always have something to do.
10 years ago I'd love to do.
I always have something to do it because if I'm not doing anything,
all right,
I want big show about crime.
Last week I did one about criminal stories,
a whole one man show.
I already have pages and pages of years have written down shit on computers,
just a different order.
So when I write one of these shows,
all I have to just go back to that page.
Why don't you just write the shit out?
This is what I did for three years.
I just got high and wrote.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I didn't know about apostrophes,
how to spell.
They're there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you forget all the shit in your,
yeah,
you forget all that shit,
but you just wanted to get the ideas out there.
Unless a man,
every comic has jokes and we have great jokes in the log rid of this,
you become a better performer.
To think that's accentuates us is our lives and how we put it into our act.
And if you don't put your life into your active,
you're just the comedian.
And I didn't know that till one night I was listening to one of our friends on a
show to her special and he's one of our friends.
It's a weird different bid comic from the store and he always just said jokes
like I was doing for years.
I was in the other room and I heard him and I go,
this is why I'm not successful because of just do what jokes.
I'm not told them about me.
What would I see with my eyes?
The world of my eyes by Depeche mode is one of the greatest gems ever.
They just break it down.
It takes a while.
The other figure out what you are saying,
what your message is.
You remember what it was like when you were 20 or 21 you didn't have enough
fucking valid opinion on anything and I'm,
Brian is 37 he struggles with this olive.
God bunches.
My brother,
he already said it.
What did he say?
Said it earlier.
It's talking about his friends lying about us.
Taxing the labeling.
Amber is in Vegas and she asks,
is there a olive garden in Vegas?
I don't know who playboy Ambrose.
I assume that's one of your friends.
That's a beautiful name though.
She's a beautiful girl.
Shizam Ooh dog.
Very excited about this time.
But it's fun.
It's fun time.
It's a great time to do shows.
We have a show Wednesday to Wednesday.
Yeah,
Wednesday a 200 episode,
which is tomorrow.
Yeah.
Tomorrow at the Ice House and a there's a show 8:00 PM show at 10:00 PM 10:00 PM
show,
10:00 PM show tomorrow at the Ice House and it's in the big room,
which is still pretty small.
It's all like 150 seats,
right?
200 cause of 290 or 200 whatever it is.
It's awesome.
It's one of the best clubs in the world.
It's a there.
Dig.
Just celebrated their 50th anniversary if you can believe it or not.
It's the oldest ones.
The oldest.
It did plays,
oozes character.
I mean it's just been around forever.
It oozes it.
It's just a,
oh it's like a museum.
Like you look around the walls and shit.
There's like all this like really old headshots and old contracts and old album
covers and sharing social security number.
Yeah.
We looked at one of them and Brian goes,
that's David Letterman,
his social security number.
And then we like get the manager over here and go,
you know,
you could read his social security number.
Like I hope he didn't change his and they put up as God damn contract from like
1976 or whatever the hell it was.
Paul.
Yeah.
All they whited it up.
I don't think they did.
Yeah,
we read it.
We read it out.
Yeah.
They didn't,
they didn't,
they took on the picture immediately when they divided it out.
Ah,
yeah.
But we uh,
you're welcome Dave.
Yeah.
Dave,
he might've just got lucky.
Dave could have been one of those things.
Yeah.
Give me something that you found on your show now.
Do you really want to go up there and stutter in front of the luck?
Yeah.
You will let him in.
If you had to choose between one show,
if you could give on one Kimmel,
I hundred percent Campbell.
He's the hippest,
right?
He's not,
he's just the coolest guy.
Nicest guy.
Have you seen a Kimmel's million or it's movie the movie?
What they,
he came,
oh did this thing,
it's a short seven minute video or something like that.
And it's called movie the movie.
It's a movie trailer about a fake movie,
but it has almost every single actor you can think of in the movie.
And it's so fucking great that now they're showing it in movie theaters before
movies because it's so good.
Yes.
If you go to Youtube and Creek,
a movie,
the movie,
I think Kamala has his own youtube page,
but it's fucking brilliant.
It's great.
So have a lot of,
but I'll tell you why I love it dude.
Because I have a 30 years ago we'll let a bit was fucking hip and how hippie was
and how bad of a mother fucker.
Cause he was gone with the anti guests and that's what nobody remembers.
The,
if you want to see a great performance,
go to youtube and fucking Rick.
Fuck.
What's the black do for Buffalo?
The seg,
they're the ones that die.
The cracked.
We should Rick James on a little bit.
Watch what comedy was.
Watch what hue bulb was.
What he want up there with a white suit
on.
And he sang 69 times.
Really?
And he would put his tub that when he sat down with them and look them,
he,
because that was quite a soul that I'll get Christmas out.
That's a lot of it was the Shit Jack.
That's been another time he brought it.
You know,
he brings his dogs.
He brought up the police dog from Kennedy airport and he's like,
show him what the dog is doing to her.
Finally he goes,
can I ask you a question?
Let's put this dog into the audience just to see if anybody's got drugs.
It's 20 fucking years.
Oh my gosh.
So he was very yet,
and she has now.
He's all to now,
people will go on.
There are solid shows or it's not just about people going on and talking with
Rick.
James got on,
watch the interview,
didn't promote nothing I didn't get was tired,
man.
Yeah,
he's tired.
How people get booked five days a week,
five days a week,
30 fucking years.
You gotta be fresh.
You got to look good.
You don't want to perform to fucking battle.
He contract bitch five shows a fucking week.
Look at Chelsea handler.
What she's doing is rough.
You run out of shit sometimes.
Yeah.
You know find ways when we only do this the most we've ever done.
This is like four days in a row.
We did that every day.
I have no writers sit down.
Your commercial breaks.
You Watch that live is why I don't agree with Saturday night live is because
when you watch the end of it,
look at how many writers they got.
She got 40 writers for this shit.
I'd rather you have four write a masterpiece.
You have 40 writers and you still do with jokes about,
I got the Dick.
It looks like you're going to die.
Seriously,
40 fucking writers.
This is why I don't get it.
I don't want to stay here.
You're a bit in the deck.
Is that a poison job?
But I fucking joke that my uncle got big,
the Dick Blaze snakes where he called the guy and the doctor says,
you got to suck it up,
and he hung up the phone.
He goes,
what did he say?
It looks like you're going to die.
That's the third grade Joe.
I seen that fucking thing.
So you've got 40 fucking writers,
you know hard.
It is to do let them it every day.
You got to look at topical Shit.
You looking at government shit.
I mean that's a tough job.
If he does five shows a week,
you know,
sometimes you look sad because you've got a great guest.
Sometimes wonder if somebody goes out of their fucking punk or something like
that.
You're going to save the show with animal tricks.
It's 1130 at night.
Well he's a notoriously hard on himself too.
He's one of those guys that after it's over he gets angry.
And since getting parents that show socks and like really,
really gets hard on himself,
what can be idiots?
What was that like?
We killed and we suck.
I've couple of,
we kill,
we go home.
We can't fall asleep.
Well sometimes it feels good,
but most of the time there's like one thing that you're still struggling with
trying to put it in order.
Even if you had a great set where they give you a standing ovation.
If you beloved one joke,
that one billable,
fucking horny on them.
But I've been with your backstage where you get off stage and you've killed and
you look at Brian and you say,
I forgot to do that joke just killed.
But we forgot to do that.
How hard are we on ourselves,
mother fucker?
I wrote that all fucking night.
I killed him.
I had him and I fucking forgot the joke.
So you just killed somebody else.
A big fucking
somebody else who said fuck the joke mastery.
I go home bound in that car ride on the way home.
I'm figuring out that said why?
I said that.
Why did I make it better?
And I got a pad and pencil the fucking car.
Now a little notepad,
which is worse than texting,
which is by the way,
another reason why you should get a fucking iPhone.
Cause that voice memos from the,
I got the fucking voice.
Voice Memos syncs up to your car.
So I got [inaudible] right off the stage and then boom,
it starts in your set.
Right.
Incredible.
The only thing is I don't know what the fuck is going to go.
So I put the format is I put the pad and Pencil Right fucking next to me and
that's it.
We got to rock this fucking closest beach,
unload this mother fucker.
I love them as opposed to shore.
Dude,
you're the best.
When you up the best.
You're the best very much for having me here.
You have enriched my life considerably,
Joe.
Da Da.
Right?
Listen,
we've had some fucking great times together,
man.
And uh,
I ain't go nowhere.
I still remember the 20 fucking years.
You are.
Listen,
I'm done.
I'm not guessing.
I think,
uh,
you know,
you,
uh,
being with us and I'm one of the reasons why I'm really excited about you coming
to Atlanta is like we said,
I never did a deal.
The first special I did or the first CD I did was in 1999.
That's the only thing I've ever done without Joey did.
But I was the cover.
Yeah,
he was all covered.
I was at the cover,
the cover naked
CD.
Usually somebody has a CD,
they open it.
It's a picture of them hanging out,
smoking a joint drink and it'd be a no.
You put a picture of me with my nut sack out and my stomach ride over it,
which only a few people still have that picture.
I have a bunch of those.
I still have that picture.
We've got a sign of a bunch of those cds.
I have those cds.
I have a stack of,
yeah,
we've got to sell those on the road because they're there.
They clap.
You could blow that up.
It's $147 on fucking Amazon man.
He can't even get that CD anymore.
I I to figure out a way to get it reprinted or something like that.
I don't own it.
Warner Brothers owns it was my first CD was a Warner brothers CD.
We'll talk to him cause I would love to get it put on bugs up.
I only have,
I have a stack of them in my closet and that's about it.
But they're,
they're like stupid expensive on Amazon because then you can't buy him new.
But that photo of you,
yeah,
I mean that was a,
I was a Joey Diaz fan from the fucking beginning.
This was,
we did that CD in 1999.
You know,
I was today we took pictures with these creepy crazy strippers that boyfriends
were there,
puffer them up.
But yeah,
it was real weird.
Disgusting.
There was a bay room.
They were that we wanted to get girls that look like they had been partying,
you know,
we didn't want like the best looking girls.
We run a girls that were pretty,
but girls that were mileage.
Yeah,
they had mileage on them.
We were looking for a certain look,
like I wore a tie and a suit jacket and so we,
uh,
took pictures basis at this.
They looked like they got run over the fucking bus.
That one chick's pussy was flat like that.
Like,
oh,
like a fucking,
it was just flat.
It had no luck to it.
Nothing.
There was a lot of stuff going on there.
Their boyfriends were the weirdest thing though.
When you get to that,
that's sort of a weird,
uh,
there's a lot of dudes that like,
bill find a girl that's like a stripper and they just like mooch off the girl to
the heads
of your confidence.
You've done this before.
Go off days shop how beautiful you are.
A lot of guys don't want,
you know guys who were successful,
they don't want the girlfriend's out there rubbing their pussy on somebody's
pants.
Yeah.
Amen Son.
So a lot of it is like girls who they find guys that have to deal with that
because the guys didn't have any money.
So they have these weird relationships with a woman is the one that makes the
money and the guys sorta like that the guy was stays home and shit and you know,
carries their,
their luggage when they go on the road with them and stuff picks him up and he's
security.
Jesus called mother fucker security shit.
Anyway,
by Abby Rogan's in Louisville,
Kentucky,
red bands at the ice house running shit.
I sound smart tomorrow,
Wednesday night,
10:00 PM come on down Pasadena.
This is going to be a fun fucking show.
And it will be our 200th podcast.
Sorry if you don't make it Wednesday,
we have one Friday off,
so just got to icehouse comedy.com but you won't be there because you'll be in
Louisville checking me out.
Bitches,
Duncan Trussell at the Louisville Improv.
Holla at your boy Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
Tickets available online tickets from Miami (305) 441-8200 call right now,
cock suckers,
mad flavor on Twitter.
Follow him.
Follow his red band on Twitter and I'm,
my name is Joe Rogan.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight,
you can enter in the code name Brogan and save yourself 15% off to number one
sex toy for men and we thank them for being our first original sponsor here on
the Joe Rogan experience.
Thank you to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
a makers of Alpha brain shrimp sport shroom,
tech,
immune and new mood.
All of them explained in great detail on onnit.com o n N.
I t.
First order,
30 pills you use,
there is a 100% money back guaranteed.
You don't even have to soon pills back.
You just get your money back.
We don't want anybody to get ripped off.
And I will tell you with 100% honesty,
this is all stuff that I take and I've taken it even before I ever started
selling it.
Yo.
So that's it.
That's the end of this fucking episode.
I love you.
I love the shit out of you guys.
For Real.
Thanks to everybody.
Thanks on Twitter and Facebook and all your delicious pitches and we will see
you tomorrow with the Great Duncan Trussell and another episode.
That would be number 200 oh shit.
And then the big show,
the breastfeeding.
Thank you.
Love you.
Bye.